straight up right all right
this is pinned so i can take here for
free but check
this city
keeping baby
check over
all the ways
right here beautiful
this wins something right
[Music]
here so he has to go in let me play this
and the rook is pinned so he has to go
back
wait no no he just take but no no the
rug is still defending
oh we can take like that so i just take
here
all right guys we're getting closer 20
minutes
here here because you cannot take we're
getting a
mother made right
is this already a sack this early all
right
takes takes takes a check he goes over
here
i play here he plays here or something
and i play here
like it has to be winning
the question is do we do we go
check first no that's no good check so i
guess we played knight up
but new main one yeah good smooth
smooth as a baby's butt
here i opened up for my queen at least
two maiden one
he's queening in one black to move
[Music]
here
it has to be here no wait i didn't do
the line properly
a better to be patient right
[Music]
all the way over flux
takes
oh i cannot take that one
[Music]
here now here's and i can't move
well they can move there but then i'd go
check again
oh that's gonna be a good night tonight
guys can you feel it can you feel the
love from chad
[Music]
oh my green screen does not like my
water bottle
oh no
all right so what did he just do he took
a pawn
[Music]
looking sharp thank you i thought if i
look better i play better right
i will like this easy puzzle
no oh here this is flying so he has to
go but then i play here
i'm scared diagonal there my rook is
being hit here
check can't go this side so you have to
go over here
[Music]
run in here now then i go here and win
the rope right
i hope i play well that's really what i
care about to be fair
i could play here to win a pawn he can't
take back because they take care
check as well it's not might not be that
way here
and this and this line oh that's not the
line
here here here here
and this is back too so yeah i think
this is good
made with a check
so this is check whoops
this is a nice fork
this king is all the way away here so
it's mostly not a king
i think but i guess
if i move somewhere with frets
then he has to take and i take here
right yeah
i've never seen this one before a little
weird
oh i take queen of course and then
yeah yeah thank you jeff
i wish i could have you in my back
pocket like in my ear or something but
that would be cheating and we don't want
to cheat
cheating is bad here hits the queen
also have oh wait it's just a discovery
right
all right like check
[Music]
take sex
thanks takes
oh that doesn't hit the queen
[Music]
so
trainer cocoona
trainer again and venusaur wait we're in
the game
we're in the game oh [__]
juice liquor i don't know dude don't
know
what to do mike is
[Music]
no matter what you do box box i will
destroy you
and it's too soon it's too soon hikaru
we didn't even reach a climax
[Music]
so
hello everybody welcome to more
pogchamps coverage i'm robert hess and
i'm
joined today by nemo of aka nebsco and
andrea from botezlive
ladies how are we doing today great
yeah i mean i'm having a good day how
are you both of you
who couldn't be excited for more
pogchamps coverage because
as we've seen from the first round of
action i think the match has been pretty
exciting
yeah i'm grateful i'm excited for my
first hog champs commentary ever
um this would be a fun experience same
here
honestly same here i mean i've done
commentary before for um
you know magnus versus hikaru for
example but this is also going to be my
first time doing podjam's commentary so
i'm so excited
well i'm pumped to have you two
alongside me and let's remind everybody
of the format of pogchamps for those of
you who may be new i don't know where
you've been but the players are split
into
four groups of four people they will
play a double round robin of rapid 10
minutes plus 5 second increment
the winners earn three points if they
head to armageddon the winners of the
armageddon will get two the loser will
get one
and the top two from each group will
move on to the championship racket while
the bottom two
make it to the constellation and as we
see the money not a bad prize day huh
nemo
yeah definitely not i mean this is this
is comparable to the best you know the
the highest tier chess tournaments out
there i'm really really
excited to see all of the amazing
gameplay that's going to happen
and all these players fighting for prize
fun in the group stage and of course the
championship bracket and even the
consolation bracket
um when it gets 3500 so not bad at all
and andrea as we see the money here some
people even if they end up in the
consolation bracket if they can go on to
win
they may even win more money on that
side of things
i saw cutie was heading for the
consolation
uh that's what she said in her interview
so you know
there's lots of hopes yeah well there
still is a long way off before we get to
the bracket stages as you see the group
stage lasts until the end of august
then we get the quarterfinals early
september the semis the finals on
september 6th
and all broadcasts will begin at 1pm
pacific
well it's a little before just like we
did today and as we look across the
groups
andre i'll start with you we're in group
a to start with today
forsen out in the lead just over gripex
who had to take it to armageddon against
scissors
do you think that fourson is the
favorite in this group
well i saw i was watching the games of
grypics
against scissors my student and so
considering that scissors almost won
that i'd say
orson is definitely the favorite but he
was rusty
but i think he's done um he's shaking
off the rust
so yeah he's definitely the favorite and
nemo as we look at today's pairings and
we know
that we're getting forcing against group
x to start
what do you think about this swede
versus dane matchup
considering that you know you're
formerly finished yeah i mean this is
this is gonna be exciting as andrea and
you know we were all talking before
can we call grypics our force and you
know neighbors and i have to say yes we
can
you know it's almost walking distance
between
denmark and sweden so this today's gonna
be really really exciting
i have to admit i haven't seen a lot of
forsen's chess gameplay but i am
i have coach gripex a little bit so it's
going to be a really really
interesting match today between both of
them um forces definitely very strong
uh so let's see let's see how well i
prepare my student
it really depends on what kind of
neighbors we're talking about because
some neighbors
get along have little potluck dinners
others are banging on each other's doors
like he turned down the music
so will they be friends will they be
foes andrea you're
you know you've also been involved with
some coaching here kind of what what are
your take
heading into this heavyweight matchup um
well
i'm not to uh be biased or anything but
i am trained for scissors just because i
coached him but i was very impressed
with carson's play
like he had a very natural intuition for
the opening and his
last round even though he has less
experience so it'll definitely be a
heavy matchup
and then xqc versus pac-man xuc
sometimes he can play obviously he's the
underdog in that match but
i think he also can see some very good
moves it'll be an interesting matchup
xqc certainly has improved he really has
and the way he was playing it's easy
with aces
it was a different xqc than we saw in
pogchamps one and nemo what do you think
of
this third match of the day between
david pakman who is favored we would say
against xqc but
do you think that the legend the wooden
shield master
can come up with an upset well this is
the part where it gets interesting
because david i feel like is a very
level-headed and solid player but he
also crumbles a little bit under
pressure as we saw
um previously so you know
anything could happen today i'm gonna go
with that anything could happen
well that seems like a bit of a cop-out
but i i also do not know and as we look
across the schedule here to remind
everybody that we will be starting with
grip x versus forzan
then we will have scissors against call
me carson live and then we will have
david pakman vs
xqc and what will undoubtedly be an
amazing day
of chess and trash talk i hope so
i was gonna add i think xqc is taking
his preparation a little more seriously
because
last match he streamed like 21 hours
before went straight in
but i saw he took a short break before
um
streaming today so maybe it'll be a
different outcome
yeah i don't think streaming for it for
anybody
for any of those who want to play in
tournaments coming up
if you plan on playing a chess
tournament streaming for 21 hours
beforehand
uh might not be the best idea of course
everybody
you know everybody has the right to do
whatever they want to
just putting that out there though
amazing a little tired yeah
it was it was just shocking i was like
looking i like i went to sleep
and you know i streamed went to sleep
woke up i was like is this
is this is this man still streaming yeah
i know you go to betty streaming
you wake up he's still streaming i don't
know he does it he's a robot or
something
yeah it's pretty it's pretty amazing
yeah he really i've seen him play among
us in all the different games so it just
what a workhorse he is and well you know
he's been improving and for
other people who want to get better at
chess they should check out the friendly
personal coaching with dr wolf
it is available on ios and android for
free so help you improve your chess
and try to become a better player with
individualized coaching
hey nemo andrea it's just a couple of
minutes away from liftoff here i'm super
excited
i'm gonna make some predictions because
i always and nemo knows this
as i say often when we have matches
i make my co-commentators make
predictions so before i even get there
andrea you're first you're the newbie
tell me what you think's going to happen
today
well i'm going to go with the safe bet
and bet on the favorite fourson
but i i definitely think gripex may win
at least one game so maybe he'll end up
in an armageddon
because he has been he played right now
he's been grinding
through these puzzles so watching his
puzzles was pretty impressive
i think he's well prepared okay yeah
that's that's your okay you agree
um honestly i would say of course
there's going to be a little tiny bit of
favoritism coming from my side because i
have coach griffix and you know he's a
he's a league streamer so
all of those things mean that i have to
cheer for him a little bit but i do
think that
um it's gonna be a really close match
probably one andrea said is really
really accurate this this match might go
to armageddon and then
um we'll see what happens in the
armageddon so i don't think
it might go to armageddon i'm telling
you definitively it is going to
armageddon i think
wow all right i think we have some
evenly matched players here
both with different strengths and
weaknesses so i feel confident saying
that one's been armed again
i like this i like this yeah robert is
here you know
telling us what's going to happen i i
really really like that
well we are here for just the most fun
possible in armageddon there's really
little that's more fun than that
and what about the second match between
scissors and call me carson
andrea you've worked with them you have
a little bit of favoritism
but what do you think's gonna happen in
that match um we'll have to see
so carson's main weakness like he played
the beginning very well his main
weakness
was like seeing tactics throughout the
end while scissors
his main weakness was also the end due
to like time pressure
but overall i mean scissors is a high
rated player and he's been playing chess
for a longer time so
i think logically scissors should win
but
maybe we'll have another armageddon
another upset
yeah i i think this will be difficult
for dick i've only
worked with carson for a little bit um
so
i i do i do think that scissors is
slightly more favorite to win in this
match
yeah scissors showed very impressive
chess surprising most people
by really being on the verge of
defeating gripex before
not really understanding blitz i don't
think he has much experience in that he
wasn't looking at his clock so that was
unfortunate for him but he played very
well there
and carson seems newer to the game and
he has some tricks up the sleeve that's
for sure he's extremely entertaining
to watch oh yeah
applause and his music he's singing
along he definitely makes chess fun
certainly does and we are about to have
liftoff here between these two players
gripex and forsen
and last but not least i'll make a
prediction between david pakman and xqc
i'm going to go david i'm going to go
with david
whoa whoa you seem very sure i'm
confident for excuses i'm sorry
i'm sorry the underdog then i'll go with
xqc
all right kill the tv we'll turn
okay well we did i'm gonna hold off on
that one for now because we do have
liftoff with the chest
it started out with e4 e5 knife three
knight f6 so once again
we see a petrol for instead of
protecting the pawn on e5 black attacks
the pawn on e4 so interesting starts
with this game
yeah this is the this is one of the
openings i did not teach cryptics how to
play so
he's he's on his own here but he's
probably going to go for the
um italian structure uh i'll bet with
the bishop on f1
so we'll see what he does what opening
did you originally coach gripex
i coached him the italian slash the
spanish you know the two openings
i play as white and black so so what
nemo
is saying for those of us uh in the
audience who are not chesmar the bishop
usually is on c4 or b5
outside of the pawn structure oh
there's attacking in the center ooh oh
that's leaving e4
undefended the interesting thing is that
these moves
like you think that they're not that
good but they're also not
that bad right because it's this level
right and it's like a lot of unexpected
things happen even if you do take the
pawn on e4 um
and and you just never know if if if
black will play it
even if black plays it what's gonna
happen okay so that's true
what i notice about beginners is many
times if there's like a free pawn in the
center
they tend not to take it because they
think it's like opening repertoire it's
prepared
yeah i noticed with hafu and pakton's
game also they just simply don't see it
because
they're not looking for it it's really
difficult actually to
even i sometimes don't even like if my
opponent gets me a pawn in the spanish
or something i don't even take it
because i'm like
this never happens yeah this is very
suspicious right exactly
well look what's happening here is that
grip he put his pawns
forward in the center of the board and
in came forces knight to e4 so
that knight on c3 is pinned it cannot
take on e4 because there is a king
behind the knight so what do you think
about this by forcing he's castle is
king
it's safer but white has the expanse
center so andre i'll start with you
whose position would you rather have
here
um i think grip still has a more
comfortable position because of the
pushing the center
the c3 square isn't too hard to defend
he could play it in one move with the
queen
and then an issue for forsen is gonna be
where is his
knight from e4 going to go once it's
attacked
okay and nemo what about you white or
black here um
i would prefer white i think i would
prefer white here
yeah so you you two are in agreement and
i think it's because of this strong
center and the fact that black's tactics
don't seem to really work out here queen
e3 was
a good looking move yeah i definitely
like this way
the way white's playing here his night
move definitely looked intimidating but
a few moves later
there's not much of a follow-up that's
possible so
right and you can see as i clicked on
the night you can see the squares you
can go to
most of them are off limits from the
night because
white has them under control so you're
not getting to any of these squares in
which case
you should probably just take on c3 and
trade it off yep
it's interesting grip chose queen d3
instead of queen c2
blocking his light squared bishop but i
think he's also trying to be more
aggressive
putting as queen as forward as possible
i honestly i i'm really really happy
with the way grip has been playing so
far
um it's like solid i mean apart from the
e4 pawn nobody nobody cares about that
pawn anyways
um everything else seems to be going
pretty well thank you very well yeah
yeah i'm looking at the chat and it's
all
about forsen right yeah i know
it isn't just forsen's chat even if he's
doing worse on the board the chat
will always be there tune which is you
know who who's the real winner here
right who's the real winner
exactly well we shouldn't let it be so
one-sided let's listen
to grip x and hear his thoughts as he
deals with this knight and bishop
hitting his knight on c3
frame will cross me right now all right
i have to say the suit was a good touch
so that's just kidding oh he's vibing
right now
right now is that musical if he goes
yeah did you also just see him steal a
night
oh yeah he just like at night too see i
told you that night was doomed i told
you i know where to go
well it could have taken c3 but you know
yeah
but but it was still doomed anyways yeah
just more likely
yeah he's coming for poor forsen's king
already but the chat will continue
cheering for forsen so i can go here
do not lose faith yeah let's go chat
oh my god he can't do much in the open
like just hitting the road why is it
going to go here oh he can go here with
chad i guess we don't want that
engraving look at this movie we have a
piece we opened up his king side
he's not allowing anyone yeah he's also
in his suit you know
he's just like vibing he's he's got his
music going all right well let's return
to
the live board that was it good to
listen into him there
but it does seem like he just stole a
piece and we'll go back to that moment
because
we're talking about it uh nemo and
andrea the knight on e4 could not go
anywhere except taking on c3
move to g5 and thank you for the night i
have two pieces hitting that square so
that's a free piece yeah i mean if grip
wanted to be even more annoying you
gotta try taking with the knight
threatening a nice checkmate yeah hit
them with that mating one threat
he was going for the queen attack also a
good attack there
but yeah he is grip is pretty much
killing this game
i i didn't realize that there was such a
big rating difference 300 points
griffin has definitely been grinding um
i know we talk a lot about you know
afu um playing a lot but grip
when i stop in my stream at around 4 a.m
i see him
starting his stream and when i wake up
he's just
ending his stream so he's like in that
eu time zone
where he's just grinding like eight
hours of chess a day as well
it's really impressive to see yeah i
really like the way he's been playing
here because
after it just a move ago when his bishop
was under attack he could have gone
to h6 which would have been aggressive
instead he brings his bishop back to e3
just to make sure that everything is
safe in the center his king
can't be checked and so that was a
really good decision i'd say by him
from the standpoint of he's up material
now he should just make sure that he
doesn't fall victim to any kind of
tactic
yeah very advanced skill for someone
who's recently learned well i'm not sure
how recent but recently learning chess
because many times when beginners are
attacking and they're winning
they forget to prevent their opponents
counter play and that's how easy you can
slip up a winning game yeah
pretty much you you i mean grip still
has his king in the center so i'm gonna
say this game is now completely over
um for first time despite you know for
something down a piece it's just that
there's always a chance when your king
is still in the center to you know
accidentally blunder something or get
checked or you know lose some material
there's always that slight chance
definitely but i like how quickly that
group x is playing because he just took
the knight in e5 he spent
two seconds on the move so he
anticipated it and reacted in a
strong way his next move will be bishop
to e2 then he will castle his king to g1
and that's where it'll be safe and sound
and i believe once he gets his king
castled we'll all think that his chances
are even greater than they already are
yeah
he knows his principles trading when
you're up material
yeah and he just did it so so what have
you been teaching yet
let's be honest yeah what's the secret
here
okay well i teach i teach everybody the
same thing i just teach them to
look for you know checks captures and
threats and the opening to always you
know develop your pieces control the
center of the castle i teach the same
thing to everybody
uh you know there's no secret that
that's what i tell people to do and then
i tell them to play the spanish or the
italian
it's a very solid security can't mess up
yeah i'm glad he's taking advice
no wonder my students do so andrea all
of our students too right as soon as we
teach them a little something they
immediately
get much stronger a chance never forget
it
never get it scissors he remembered
every piece of advice including
don't get into time pressure well andrea
you
are the absolute coaching legend because
connor
didn't even know he was going to be
playing in pogchamps yeah he gets in
there and wins his first two games so
that was fantastic i know he he messaged
me the night before i have no idea how
to play chess i have a pog champs match
we coached 30 minutes before his match
but he remembered how to checkmate and
that was all he needed
that's honestly you know you know all
you need to know in chess is to know how
to win right that's all you need andreas
for the beginner
secret yeah
he is seeing tactics in a hurry look at
this he went
pawn takes pawn yeah he immediately went
queen zebra he was
waiting for this and actually fourson
responds very well with d5
because if you take this bishop on b4
then in comes pawn to d4 right with
forking
the bishop on e3 and the knight on c3 so
a good response
by forsen but griffix he's sharp he's
alert right now
the puzzles he was doing right before
stream are definitely paying off right
now he sees them so fast
i think he's like 1700 and puzzled or
something that makes sense
yeah it's uh he you know he's he's
just doing doing making like solid moves
honestly he's
you know he's playing like objectively
very sound chess and that's
that's something to see for sure well
let's uh take a listen in with him now
that his pieces are forked but he is up
to
two miners let's hear what he thinks
about his position and his winning
chances
all right but what does that oh it
hits this but then he plays here
oh he's drawing the arrows like uh in
his calculation
look at that calculating another check
ah that's no i like that movie alright
[Music]
he's definitely looking for the checks
which is really important i think
it's like it's you know giving up the
knight
we're gonna try and see how he blocks it
against black's king
oh now
yeah he has a pretty good move now i
don't know about queen c4 maybe the
other
checklist or bishop c4
but now he doesn't actually want a piece
never mind oh my god that's not good oh
i think he sees it
he doesn't win a piece if i go here
because he's moved us so this is now
defending each other
so we yeah orson is not streaming
himself so
we can't hear his thoughts but we're
here
i'm just talking about this because
forsen
decided not to stream he's just focusing
on the chest but we see that grip is
now recognizing that bishop can come to
e6 so maybe a moment too late even
though it won't cost him here
that's one of the things that happened
in chess right you think you're making a
good move and
after you've already made the move you
realize that you
did not anticipate your opponent's
response right you see the threat
right after when it's too late yeah
i think that in this case especially
like once you
let your opponent get a little bit of
counter play in these kind of games
where king especially still in the
center it becomes a little bit risky
right because
it's just like that mentality of you
know being on the attack is always
better for you
because you find moves after move but
now if black sees bishop v6 this game
could technically
uh go in the favor of forsen right
will still be down material but it'll be
interesting because now that king will
be stuck
oh and he sees it white's king will be
in the middle on the near the foul of
black's queen
so who knows what can happen in this
game
yeah it's one of those moments where if
you start taking on c6 and the position
opens up
more and your king is still in the
center and doesn't get to castle
that's when it can become tricky however
black's king will
never be safe there are no pawns in
front to defend it so
yeah if white can get his pieces over to
that side of the board
i believe the king on jade is much
easier to start trying to checkmate than
white's king ever will be oh
um yeah i mean now it's just like if
if f takes e3 happens we'll probably see
something like
you know queen h4 check um
and the key won't have to move we'll see
g3 but then it's also like the king
white's king is still not that safe you
can of course always castle on the queen
side
but once again not the safest spot for
it um
so a lot of interesting things could
happen right now
and you did take on e3 and actually i
was going to say a pretty high level
decision would be to ignore the pawn and
i do believe
that many of the people in the pogchamps
tournament they
forget or they just think when
something's attacking them they need to
respond to that
but if gripex had just castled kingside
immediately
if this pawn took on f2 his rook would
take and open up and go after the black
king side
yeah and that would be really important
that also because black does not get
that queen h4 check in
um and you know stop white from castling
because right now
it's if your opponent's king is in the
center of the board you want to keep it
there
you want to you know i need ghosts yeah
plays for it
so far has been playing pretty sharp um
for the position he's in
curious if grip is still going to go for
g3 because
a little bit scary with the light
squared weaknesses but it is his best
move
yeah to show andrea's point here is if
g3 let's say queen h3
you cannot castle through check that's
illegal so the queen will cut the king
off
from the king side and if you go
queenside there's a lot of open space
over there
because there aren't too many pawns
shielding the king
you'll have to have faith in the
queenside cast
i this is yeah this is one of those
positions where it's like you know the
eval bar says that white is completely
winning here
but over the board and especially with
this kind of time control
it's it gets a little bit messy it gets
a little bit messy and
and seeing this game you know the clock
stick down we might even see like a
little bit of a time scramble so
lots of chances still for forsen to hold
this game we know the evol bar says
white is significantly better and white
is of course up a piece
okay this is queen g4 squeegee five is
also a good move hitting e3 so if you
play castle right now queen takes
e3 is going to be really strong yeah i
like horses moves a lot
he's definitely putting up really good
counter play and i i think
as you two can attest to better than i
can but for some of the players in
pogchamps they're not always good at
retreating
finding moves that go backwards but also
help them out so move like here
queen e4 would help or queen f3 would
help defend this pawn on e3
but it's not so easy to retreat your
queen when it's in such an aggressive
position so
do you think oh wow he answered it he
put his queen on e4 i was going to say
that
of all the players i think grip x has
that under control
yeah i was gonna say just from the
beginning when he played that bishop
retreat move
i was gonna say his instincts have a
very good defensive instinct even when
he's winning so
i expected him to see it and for forsen
he can play bishop
f5 to try to challenge this queen and
nemo it's what you've been saying all
along that
if the king doesn't find true shelter
it's going to be a difficult
task for grebex to convert this well
after rook the eight this is the perfect
time for white to castle
um because getting a rick onto f1 also
staff push f5 and then your queen is
very very safe on e4 and you'll forever
be defending your e3 pawn
um so you know it's
castling is is a very logical move here
it's very logical
i wonder though if group x will be
somewhat concerned about a rook to d2
type of move when the rook gets to the
open file you concern yourself with what
what if it gets
all the way down to the seventh rank
where it attacks the pawn on b2 and
also just stare through the bishop
towards the king side
that is true yeah the problem is if he
doesn't castle now it will be too late
like
forsen could play a future rook f8 and
his king will be stuck vulnerable in the
middle
that's a really good point so we'll see
if he he's comfortable with that rook v2
threat
otherwise oh and he doesn't oh
okay so so robert is completely correct
and andre as well he was not comfortable
with the rookie two thread
um okay his king is still stuck in the
middle
but ricky one is not the worst thing
that can happen if your king's in the
middle of the board
and also the fact that white is up a
piece swapping off pieces is pretty
decent you know you'll be you'll be
winning the end game if all the pieces
come off but
um it's just about you know where does
he actually plan on putting this king
because there's still queens on the
board
yeah and bishop f5 played now to try to
challenge this bish the queen excuse me
away from the pawn e3 so
i think we're getting the hang of the
player's ideas at this point and what
they're looking at
i just do wonder if rip x feels as
comfortable about his position so why
don't we tune in with him again to hear
his thoughts as the position is getting
more complicated
yep chuck what does that do right
all right it hits these strong arrows
he's attacking my queen and then i have
to get out
honestly a very interesting move here
with the bishop to c4 and after
if if black plays kh8 i think um
i think white could try
rook takes d8 let's see i don't know if
he's gonna see that
it's a little bit i could play here he
takes
and i take i need to take trading rooks
here would be a good tactic
but he has not calculated that move yet
oh he's going for the check
yeah well bishop c4 there's king h8 rick
takes the a bishop takes two three
four okay
um it's just a question of how is he
going to deal with the epoch after
black plays something like eight
and i also think he's very calm he seems
like he's calm who's common in the first
time that is not too good right
defending
very well here we're treating his bishop
one of those things that we said earlier
was difficult for the level players to
find
yeah i mean he's got his basics down
pretty
well he's just gonna keep checking my
questions how can i protect him
i have to point out earlier forsen was
down on time by like almost two minutes
and now they're equal
so forsen may be able to put group x
into some time pressure
to help balance out his uh this again
this is definitely not over i'm only at
two minutes this is it's far from over i
think
at least i'm pretty successful
wow okay okay well that's a really good
tactic for white here i don't know if
griffith is going to see it but if he
runs through his you know forceful
movement oh he stole it
very quickly because why did i ever
doubt my student
i know because you felt that doubting
him would be encouragement that he was
true he was going to prove me wrong it's
better than jinxing it
yeah telepathy you know he understood he
heard you saying it he was angry he's
like of course i'm going to get it and
now
very nice his tactical vision right now
is just second to none in this
tournament
his tactics are very strong that's just
a free piece
in the center of the board he's now up
two minor pieces however
the king only one it can't castle and
there are going to be checks in the very
near future available oh that's not the
way to go
oh oh dear game
yep oh he says he messed up
forsen was fighting hard but missed that
one tactic
yeah i mean it's a very difficult
position for
black regardless of where your king goes
um i i think even if you go to g7 or h8
you're still losing your rook through
queen f6 or
um so maybe yeah checkmate soon
yeah it's gonna be both right you can
just win that rook and then deliver a
checkman there actually is
a forced checkmate as you can see the
evaluation bar it says check me at four
moves
and the way you do that is by playing
queen f6 check it forces the king
back to g8 then you take this rook on d8
the king is only one safe square you
bring your queen to f8 and after king up
there's rook f6
bring in the final piece for the
checkmate let's see
yeah there's also rook f7
yeah and queen f6 and he's gonna move
away
there we go oh my god what a game
[Music]
he's excited he's ready to go oh no
i think this game will motivate forsen
though because towards then he started
playing
better like defending very well so who
knows maybe this
loss will motivate forsen and the tables
will turn next game
yeah it's all right chad um you know
we're still
we're still of course there's a lot of
hope here first it says
no yeah no we don't we don't bring out
the savages
we don't bring out the sadness yeah
today anything can happen
robert what do you think it still
happened no no i don't have an
armageddon so
i i guaranteed it you know i didn't
suggest it is guaranteed
that forsten is going to win game two
and if we go back to the ninth move of
this game
because that's where it all turned in
grip x's favor
when he brought the queen up to d3 then
unfortunately for forcing he brought the
knight to a square that wasn't under his
control you have to
always look out to see how many pieces
protect the square
in this case white has two pieces in the
g5 square and black had only
one queen defending so knight g5 simply
lost a piece and after that
grip x converted pretty flawlessly
honestly
[Music]
yeah there were little bits in there
where forsen um
had a chance but i mean being a piece
down is not easy and gripix is already
really really strong
so you know this just goes to show at um
at a certain level when you lose your
when you
start losing material it it becomes a
really difficult game to play so
forzan's goal for next game would be to
you know not lose that piece
early and to bring grip into a longer
game because forsen definitely has his
chances
but being a piece down just is really
difficult
really really difficult absolutely and
forsen now with
the white pieces he starts out with
the nemo bishop on c4 we have
the italian game i like this yay
and oh wow so what have you taught
gripex and your other students about
italian maybe you don't give away all
the secrets
what have you gone over in the general
principles um
honestly this is exactly what i've
taught grip to play he was
he used to be scared of the fried livers
i told him to play the italian i'm a
bishop c5 as as black and
oh d4 here i don't know that is a very
very early d4 um very similar to what we
saw earlier
oh my gosh so forsen has been studying
that is what this tells you because
if you look at the d4 square black has
one
two three pieces covering it and white
doesn't have only is one two pieces
defending it so
d4 gives away a pawn but to play e5 and
challenges black's knight and f6 so
andrea this knight has to move
it seems unless grip x can find the move
d5
yeah this is the ponziani um
but you know i i i did not show grip
this opening i i feel like for a
beginner the natural movement
for your knight back but he must be so
confused because it's like this opening
should be working for black you know
all the theory checks out he's played
this a million times before he's never
but he's never
seen um d4 e takes d4 so i
doubt he's going to be able to see oh
yeah this is what i was saying blunder
well yeah i think if d5 black
probably may have been better but now
with that passive move
it is going to be the classic knight g5
threat on f7 that he can't stop
yeah d5 is a very hard move for people
to play without knowing it because
as we've been talking about once a piece
is under attack most
of the players in pogchamps they react
by moving that piece
right that's that is a natural reaction
the knight goes back to g8 because
that's a very safe square
but the problem with doing this is now
you've undeveloped
and white's king is already on g1 so
nemo you see this
you're an italian player you kind of
have a more open position than you're
used to
but shouldn't you be happy about white's
chances white's chances in this position
are amazing
even even if rookie one was not the um
you know the
eval bars first choice pretty much no
matter what y plays here black's gonna
be in
some kind of trouble i think i think
maybe a preferred move there was maybe
just knight g5 straight away
um because you know you just go for the
attack but but this position is good for
white too there's just so many things
that work here 95 now really really good
move
you're going to bring your queen out
next move to attack h7 and f7 you know
i don't know if force is an aggressive
player i haven't really watched enough
of his games to
to know but knight g5 is very intuitive
it's like a better version of the fight
liver which everybody loves playing
so yeah oh if he played
d4 um i expect him to be a resident
alex is trying to be smooth thinks we
can't see her if she hides behind a big
piece of fabric
i was waiting for the doves to come out
i was like oh it really looks like she's
playing a magic trick and she's wearing
a mask inside i don't know what she's up
to
no good yeah that was awesome that was
awesome well
she definitely has the colors oh she's
just crawling underneath
alex we can see you you're not smooth
you're right there okay alex how's it
going
when i'm streaming and my mom like
brings me food she like
get on the ground like crawl so yeah
camera doesn't see her but
it doesn't work all right oh well
all right magic trick is over that was a
new type of botez gambit and we were all
here for it i'm glad we could be a part
of it
and forsen made the move c3
which trades away the pawn that he
sacrificed this d4 pawn for
the c3 pawn but that also allows his
knight to get out so
nemo i ultimately agreed with you that
knight g5 was a
much stronger move and it goes for the
direct threat on f7
but what do you make of this c3 move
andrea like do you like that move do you
think that
he's kind of understanding the position
or now after d5 are you
thinking that grip originally i thought
he had pretty good instincts with c3
because he's trying to develop
his knight if they take and if they
don't take he obviously wins a free pawn
opening up the file near near the king
too so i think it is a good idea
okay well ripbacks responded with d5 and
now
forcing took on d4 you see the
evaluation bar
what is going on here interesting
we i don't know if this raid was too
good for
yeah and the reason why is there's a
bishop on c5 under attack and there's
also a bishop on c4 under attack because
of the pawns
so that means if i can move my bishop
away from c5 since black's turn
and attack something then this bishop on
c4 can be captured next
bishop b oh my gosh grip x oh the test
is
tactics dude his tactic is probably
better than mine at this point
he doesn't miss a single tactic
that was great vision by him to realize
that he could play d5
and then after the capture back on d4 he
moves his bishop to b4
and attacked two pieces at the same time
so the chat
the swedes in there they seem to not be
so thrilled but
the danes they seem to
be quite happy with gripex's performance
um
yeah originally i thought forsen was
doing much better with his opening as
white he just missed that one
winning knight b5 idea so but it's still
not game over
yeah well i think i think the thing
about you know playing these kind of
aggressive openings is
first i don't really know how much crap
foursome has done
but if you're going to go for something
as aggressive as this and your opponent
you know puts his knife back and then
you have like this kind of you know play
in the opening it's
you gotta capitalize on that you don't
really have time even if c3 was
objectively speaking not
a bad move you just don't really have
time to do moves like that because it's
all about the aggression it's all about
putting your pieces
up before your opponent can get his
pieces out so
right and just to highlight it once more
nemo is correct knight g5 it have castle
to try to protect the f7 square in comes
the queen to h5 and it hits
h7 with a check mini threat hits f7
that's three pieces attacking that
square it would have been devastating
that would have been a good find for
forsen
i'm just like you know really kind of
kind of surprised at how determined
gripex looks like
uh you know how determined he has to win
this tournament it's it's a different
kind of determination i've seen
you can tell his confidence is back
because earlier the very first
few moves of this game he looked like
less confident now he's chilling
drinking his energy drink
he was puffing earlier so he's
definitely feeling his confidence
he's feeling it for sure he's feeling
yeah and he's also up
two minutes on the clock and i think we
haven't quite stated how important that
is because
even when some of these players get good
positions they at times
do not have the remaining time
available to them to work through the
complications and so gripex
is playing well and he's playing quickly
so he can serve time for later in the
game
when he needs it to work through the
tactics definitely
yeah he's using the same killing
strategy using the last game now he's
going to be up material he's going to
keep his time
i don't think he's going to allow any
space for blunders or counter play so
it'll be tough for forsen to fight back
again and i'll add that it's a very
different grip x than in his first
matching scissors because
oh yeah their scissors was kind of
pushing grip x
in some of the positions at least thus
far there hasn't been a single moment
where well with knight g5 was the
exception but that wasn't found by
forsen and so it feels like grip x is
the one with
the better control of the games
yeah um i mean right now grip is just
you know up up in exchange um
forsen has a little bit of compensation
for it and the fact that he has a center
he has the pair of bishops it's still
not too late for him to reroute his
bishop back to maybe c2 and then
you know go for knight g5 ideas but um
being down material is definitely like i
would say one of those things you don't
want to do
a king's grip x because griff is really
strong with his tactics and
he does not miss he does not miss and i
have to say
wow i i underestimated griffix when uh
robert asks us to say who we think we're
gonna win because in the first match
against scissors scissors was crushing
him grepix only won because scissors
dropped a piece
um and now he seems like he made a
substantial amount of progress he's
seeing every tactic
so much stronger than from the first
round yeah and it's
it's one of those things right like when
you're starting out in a tournament you
you mess up a little bit you you doubt
yourself a little and you're like a
little
nervous especially playing on such a big
stage uh but once you get like a little
bit more accustomed to everything
you know grip x's group x is doing well
what i will say for forsen here is that
a rook
is worth more points than a bishop we
all know that but
there's not open lines so the rook on a8
the rook on
f8 they're sort of struggling to get
into the game
whereas the minor pieces can work around
the closed position a bit better
for instance this bishop as nemo
mentioned can come to c2 to aim at the
king
the bishop on d2 well i would want to d2
but it can later move out and
f6 i was about to say this is the type
of move you play
to open up the board but there's huge
risk in the position along the e file
staring all the way down to the square
e6 so if
orson takes on f6 now there will be
tactics
that grip x has to be alert for
definitely
that is a great point um yeah here in
the middle game forson wants to keep the
position closed he could aim all his
pieces towards h7
so now um grip has to take a risk and
try to open it which is actually
ruining i mean not ruining his position
but making it slightly worse
yeah i know the bishop g5 yes yes the
bishop g5 might be a
really strong oh and he plays it oh my
goodness i don't know
he did not need much time to play that
either he was ready for him the problem
for black is rook g6
you'll notice there's a pin on the
knight on e7 and now bishop c2
is extremely powerful because i'm
attacking your rook
and your rook has nowhere to go and your
bishop on e6 needs the defense as well
so you typically play bishop f5 but
the knight on e7 is pinned so after
bishop takes f5 you cannot take back
with your knight
otherwise you lose this queen on d8 i
know that's a little far down the line
but it just goes to show how free
white's pieces are and how much of a
struggle it is for black's pieces to get
coordinated right now
definitely i'll see if forsen can take
the lead here bishop c2 and
he'll be better
yeah wow um i mean this is a very very
kind of like you know it's
anything could happen like we've said
before and it's just like a forsen sees
bishop c2 which is
you know totally within within his
sights because it's an attacking move
right it attacks the wreck
yeah i have confidence yeah i have
confidence too
this game could totally go in white's
favor and then we might even see that
armageddon
yeah robert will be right what did i say
about the word might no we
are going to see we are right we are
going to see we have full confidence in
seeing the armageddon i'm not
rooting for either player i don't root
for people however
i just know coming into this match this
is
no he didn't play visually oh he hit
them with the h4
that's a good plan but now we were to
see the power of the jinx it's better to
doubt that yeah it's better to damage
we gotta say it in a way like we don't
think you'll see it yeah
wait wait wait h4 is one of those moves
that causes
the pog champers to worry because they
see that pawn coming
and they want to react to that pawn
remember this knight on e7 is still
pinned and bishop g4 was played
but d5 is now hanging because the knight
on e7
is pinned so knight takes d5 here would
be
a huge opportunity for forsen because
after knight takes d5
i wish i could drag on the proper square
you cannot take me back with your knight
otherwise you'll lose your queen
and i'm threatening discovered checks on
your king with his bishop on b3
yeah i think uh forsen had a mastermind
plan here h4 a pseudo tactic
ignoring the best move bishop c2 because
he knew grip would just crumble with
this
not the best move but harder to play
against
i told you you see h4 you need to react
to it and then knight takes d5 comes you
see that there's a pin
on your knight on e7 let's actually
we'll listen into grip x to hear how
he's analyzing his position if he
realizes
just how bad his positions become
yeah oh my god it's nasty boys is nasty
because when he moves the night he gets
check i have to move king right
but then i loose of peace damn that's
solid murphy
damn so i have to go here
yeah he realizes he takes oh yeah he
knows
he's the tactic master he doesn't
underestimate this
yep um you know with all the all the
talk we had about
grip picks you know being really really
good attackers i'm a little bit
surprised that he missed this one i have
to move king
just because you know there's a lot of
pieces of attacking d5
what if it's something it's one
[Music]
consequence definitely i think it i
think it's all a little bit part of
um you know getting a little bit
confident
this has to be the best move i think
here
here oh no god well
that it's going to be on again in time
soon it's going to be armageddon we're
going to go to armageddon i guess
so let us return to uh the live analysis
board
so you two were like oh no not rookie
six and the reason why he played rookie
six was because
he thought that he was stopping the
discovered check which he did
right the bishop on b3
it's no longer a check but he took the
rook on e6
he missed the double check not one of
them but not both
and now he's going to lose basically all
of his minor pieces and
uh you find force i will 100 win this
end game
oh bet the king oh all right well we
might even see force and checkmate yeah
and now
95 is killer yeah do we think foursome
is going to do that or is he going
yep oh my gosh beautiful we were talking
about grip x's tactics
but what about forsen's tactics in this
game he just needed to warm up a little
bit
the first game was a warm-up game now
now forces away
now exactly now he sees the tactics just
as much as griffix does
and for everybody listening that
ambulance is not on my end of things for
a chance that's me in new york
that is andrea in new york and here is a
piece hanging oh take it with a bishop
on e7
and that way it removes
oh no forsen
that was a game over whoa
he's still he still has a winning
chances though i thought it was
fully game over but never mind no it's
it could go towards a draw now but now
foursome is a very good chance to just
take the knife and take the queen
um or or a lot of other moves in that
position would have worked me too
poor guy the knight on e7 was hanging
and the king would have to move and then
you could have taken this queen on d5
and
moved on to win but or you stick in the
night with your queen or
that also works right but queen f7 the
problem is you've just given away your
extra piece
and rooksy one is a very good move by
forsen because
he's trying to get on the open file but
look at [__] x
he's going to put his pawn on c6 and
this is where knights can be better than
bishops
the bishop on g5 can never touch this
knight on d5 because on a light square
so c6 helps solidify that knight's
stand on d5 and well let me ask you two
nemo andrea
is this going to be a draw or is forsen
somehow
going to pull this one out uh
i don't know what to say because part of
it is that once you miss
like once you have we're so winning and
now it goes into this
it goes downhill quickly from my
personal experience you're winning
now you still like kind of have to win
the match right and it's just like hard
converting your mentality to just focus
on the now and not focus on the past so
it's it's difficult difficult
yeah we'll have to see how strong his
mentality is here
just from a practical point of view when
you look at this position i'm trying to
get into the minds of the players
so forsen he's upset as you're saying
nemo he's up a pawn
so that's good and then from gribex
you're like well
it was worse before and how is my
opponent actually going to look at his
move rookie eight
going to the open file i actually think
the position is easier to play
in many regards for black than it is for
white
yeah yeah he is forcing is up a pawn but
he has an isolated pawn on d4
that's very hard to defend extended pawn
h4 that's not defended by anything so
he has a worse pawn structure even
though he's up a pawn
i'm not liking this too much for white i
have to be honest just in terms of
position
i mean he is still up the pawn so
there's always chances but
black just has so much peace activity
and the knight on d5 will never be
kicked away
so and okay he's gonna get one of the
pawns back now actually
and the good news i mean the best news
for gripex is the
lead on the clock and in addition that
when his pawns are attacked he can react
and that's the thing that i keep talking
about is that
hog champers they react sometimes when
they shouldn't directly
to the threat here the immediate threats
can be parried and so look here the pawn
on b7 is under attack
move your pawn play e6 oh oh
that's not a good move because now your
queen side pawns are in more trouble
the knight was so good on d5 now there's
more drawing chances that they've taken
away all the minor pieces and it's equal
pawn
and this is also a wreck-in game so i
honestly think that white has pretty
good winning chances with just the fact
that um
his pawns are a little bit more solid
than blacks right now yeah that trade
was not in his in grypic's favor
and these pawns on c6 and a6 now are
easy for
forcing the target rook a3 or rook c3
coming next
and actually rook a3 will directly win
this a pawn and the rook on h4
it took stole a pawn that was the good
news the bad news is it's far away from
the queen side and cannot help in the
defense over there exactly
the only he trapped his rook off from
defending because he can't go
to the h6 square while white's rook is
reactive and it can easily attack
black's pawns
and here goes forcing rook a3 played
quickly
uh mind you so that you could take the
a6 pawn and
two minutes and 12 seconds so we like
forsen's position
but what do you make of the time
situation does that give grip x
much better chances to survive this i i
honestly think that at the time is not a
big deal in this position
um both players are going to be playing
pretty fast anyways just because there's
less pieces on the board and you know
the ideas are fairly simple for them
it's just you know you go for pawns you
go grab the pawn
i'm sure both of them know that they
need a passport in order to win the game
so i think that the time is a little bit
yeah i don't know actually i don't know
considering that
forsen came back last i mean almost came
back last game when he was down two
minutes and then he equalized on time
i think he can manage being down a
minute um
i was going to add something but it said
my mind
i i think that here uh rip x is doing
the right thing by putting the king on
d5 because
white has an extra pawn but it's you
know you look across the board like wait
doesn't white kind of have
extra pawns in different locations
there's an extra pawn on the a file
there's an extra pawn on the d file an
extra ifa from white's point of view for
black
you have an extra h pawn and an extra c
pawn so it's not a symmetrical pawn
structure with just one extra pawn
the pawns are split across the board
yeah
yeah now you can go nema no go ahead
we got that backwards pawn on e3 that
black could have easily attacked
like rookie one king e4 but white has
some interesting defense
with the rook from the seventh rank as
well
he's going for the other pawn island
he's keeping the rook on a7 tied down
for now and unfortunately
for forsen he can't play pawn to a4
because that loses the b3 pawn so rook
on b2
it just slides between these pawns and
prevents them from moving that's very
annoying
and for forsen i think he should move
his king he does to f3
which can open up e4 check in the future
however the e pawn is needed to defend
the d-pawn
frustrating situation yeah i think
what's really going to be fortuna's
winning point in this end game is the
fact that his epoch is already a pass
pawn
that's going to be so important for him
i mean obviously right now black's king
is still right ahead of
right on top of it but um oh i don't
really like b4
because it opens up now the key will no
longer be on top of the pawn
so if if oh he doesn't play it
oh okay okay they're playing oh my god
what about
here now griffix is gonna have a pass
pawn after b3 is traded
no anything could literally happen
because that pawn on b4 is going to be a
like a monster of a pass pawn yeah i
don't know if he can even stop it
here comes rook c5 check though and you
can win another pawn i think that
even as the evaluation bar swings
towards equality
i believe it's much easier to play with
the extra pawns here than is with the
pass pawn
because in end games you want to focus
on the quality of your pawns not just
the quantity
but here rook to b6 your rook is already
behind the past pawn
and then the d-pawn runs free or the the
g-pawn runs free you have your choice
oh that was a good that was an
interesting move yeah it scared me for a
second leaving the rook trade but uh
but but you promote yeah you promote
just fine but now he has to play rook b6
basically
yeah and then it's pretty comfortable
play for white nice
all right he could have taken on c3 and
they both would promote at the same time
and that would have been a winning end
game for white as well because they do
have the past pawn but
it's a little difficult to play that oh
okay rook d3 now
get behind this pawn that's what you
need to do
and he does it yeah i don't even know
how white should respond here
uh seven this is gonna be a draw
theoretically
um or or wait is this a theoretical draw
i don't know he's gonna lose this past
pawn right well
and rip x i i'm looking at his camera he
seems a bit nervous but he brings his
king to the right square
and this is a big issue for forsen it's
he pushed his pawn too far
you may be saying wait are you supposed
to push your past pawns in the end game
but if they're too far away from your
other pawns your king
they're just going to be uh tracked down
and one
as this pawn d7 is now yeah i think rook
c6 is the right way to go just accept
the draw here
um yeah but but of course forza needs to
win
right he needs to win so he can yeah the
draw is a good result for this game but
he'll lose the match
yeah in other words he has to lose
there's no drawing here
yeah you might be wrong about that
armageddon now
robert your fortune telling skills i
should have asked you to put something
on the line
yeah we should have had we just play
some bets on this eyebrows on the line
you were so sure about it
i put my dignity on the line i mean what
more could you ask yeah
what more can we want i think that
fourson should play king to e4
just as hoping to try to push and
then he'll push his g pawn these end
games even though
eventually white will have to sacrifice
this rook for this brilliant past pawn
if white can get the king up the board
and start moving the e and g pawns it
won't be
that simple for black oh
oh i think he's gonna gain more time but
but
this is going towards a three-fold
repetition king e4 here
that way yeah black queens then you get
the check-in that would be sneaky
but also oh that is a draw
it's a drawing grip x he holds on
and he wins the match one and a half
it was a good game it was a really
really high quality game it was a good
game
very impressive end game coming from
this level too i'm extremely impressed
by how grip x played in this
match and for forsen he was so close
to winning the second game but he went
queen f7 check i'll just
pull that position i know i can't one
more time
yeah that was a tough moment for him and
he was so focused on the checkmating
attack when he was up material
that i guess he didn't realize the queen
defended the f7 square
and that allowed x to get away with it
so
we are going to go on a quick break when
we return we will have the players for
an interview
you will not want to miss their thoughts
in just a few
didn't you have mate no
see i was in check or accuracies that
was a bad game dude
i need to watch i need it
so that was
this is what really [__] screwed me
that's best move why because you beat
this
or would you take bishop it's a blunder
how is that a blunder how are
either of these a blunder
tell me what
why is this a blunder
because take move
move move
huh
oh boy i didn't see your match uh my
matches start
in nine minutes this is just a game
against a friend
missed win
oh i mean i didn't see it later anyway
it doesn't matter
i needed a castle dude
oh that was such a bad game
i threw from the very start dude how do
i not see that that's
hanging there okay so
if i open up like this
i open up like this he does this i go
here
no it's saying that's a mistake
but i hate how this turned out
i don't like this
because the event that he takes and i
take
i don't understand why this is good for
me
he takes there or he challenges here
he wouldn't do that i guess you would do
that
that challenge goes here
and then i go here
why is that a blunder
what am i missing oh duh
i knew that okay
wow my chest brain is um
not up to speed quite yet
i'm up a piece oh
firing on all cylinder state we're fine
we're fine
i do how do i go to previous matches
my matches are starting soon so i have
to be
how do i i don't know how to do this on
my analysis
i want to go to the previous game
archive
this one analyze
okay
so that's fine too
okay so there i gotta protect my
so
[Music]
and as we return we welcome both gripex
and forsen to the show thank you both
for joining us and grebex
congratulations on what was a
very hard-fought win yeah thank you so
much that was
definitely uh nailbiter for me like the
last game
oh that that i was so nervous on what to
do
yeah and forsen let me ask you a quick
question because
it seemed to get away from you in the
first game at this moment the opening
was very interesting and
the knight g5 move was that just an
oversight by you that you wish you had
back
yeah yeah i just i just i haven't been
in that situation ever doing the
during this uh i think it's petrol
defense or something
uh where it's so crowded there and i
didn't have a threat and i was thinking
for the longest time about taking
uh the night yeah
but i figured uh that's so awkward
because then i had to retreat to bishop
and uh they get a good pawn structure
yeah so i was like i'm just gonna
you know back off but then i didn't
realize he had two attackers on that
square
uh for some reason so yeah i just
blundered
early on and i was just trying to win uh
a very hard game after that
so i was just yeah yeah
and unfortunate yeah i mean of course
that one got away from you but in game
two
i mean andrea and cheat and nemo you
both really loved how forsen was playing
that right
yeah definitely game two was brilliant
it was very aggressive out of the
opening i never met
someone who retreated the knight back to
the original square so that threw me off
so much
because it's not the proper play at all
so i was like wait i should i should be
able to capitalize on this but i didn't
know how because i never faced someone
who
who actually went back to original
square so it messed up my thinking and i
missed uh
amp song i think on when he pushed the
middle square and then i lost a rook for
a bishop so that was kinda
like ugh i felt bad and then i had a
mouse clip
with my bishop when i was gonna go up to
g5 oh i i dropped it on
the two i think ah here you were trying
to go to g5 oh
yeah yeah and i dropped it to d2 that is
very unfortunate
yeah but uh on your end of things gripex
your position uh was very good already
at this point you'd want some material
and you had not seen this opening before
either so
can you tell everybody what it's like to
get into a new position when
you're already probably a little bit
stressed out playing in front of so many
people
how do you calm yourself and find uh a
response i i'll be honest i just
like the written and i retreat it just
seemed logical because i couldn't find a
square but it would actually make sense
where it wouldn't
like immediately get fret somewhere else
so i felt like retreating it back and
then repositioning and on
e7 instead would be better just to help
me like control the center a little bit
more
and nemo you want to tell them what you
were looking at during the game after
rookie 197
oh yeah um here forzon had an amazing
move with knight g5
um you know just heading hitting the f7
pawn and
grip would basically have to castle
defend that one and then
white will hit hit black with queen h5
um
oh very common kind of trick ah
yeah that's very good that's right i did
not say that
but now you know this idea for future i
was very far behind the development
after i
i tried to scout forza a little bit but
i couldn't find the
any that many games other than e4
i like very standard openings so i
i got very thrown off guard on the
second game and he played it well
and there was one thing a little later
in the game where i felt like he had a
better chance uh with some
proper trading i believe yeah i [__]
up my queen
yeah yeah yeah i fighted the queen for
sure
um i don't know i just started i was
down so much on time i feel like at that
point so i just uh
i rushed it too much basically yeah
actually
i'm sorry go ahead okay good i have a
question for force in here
just about your mindset so like here you
probably felt like you were
completely winning and i noticed about
you you have a really strong
fighting spirit so like we were talking
about a common
uh obstacle for chess prayers is going
from completely winning and then having
to fight
to not lose how did you manage that
mindset from going from queen f7 and
then in an almost winning end game at
some points
i was basically i was up a pawn and i
had a
i had a knight for uh
why i had a bishop for a night so i was
clearly like up but my pawn structure
was pretty bad
uh with the one pawn in the middle so it
was very hard to capitalize on the
bishop when
the when the knight got such a good
position in the middle
it was it was it was really hard um
but then i i i figured in the end i
might as well force draw because
um it was winning for him
and i think a draw is better than two
losses
that's a good attitude i like that
attitude yes
it was a nice a nice impressive draw to
find there
yeah it worked really really well i mean
this engine was was really good honestly
it was a really good game between i
don't know where i'm where i made a
mistake though in the end
could i have one there from this
position um it's a draw
here well mostly a draw
yeah you could trade the uh the rooks
here
and then that way you queen at the same
time so
black goes and gets the queen and white
does the same your king may fall victim
to a number of checks
but of course white has no chances to
lose and only
good chances to win so that was the last
opportunity but credit to gripex for
putting up
really stubborn defense throughout that
whole end game down upon
oh it's really intense games i must say
i definitely felt the pressure in game
two and
ah this this group is very very close in
terms of
just all performance it feels yeah and
those uh
you know grip x you deserve a huge
congratulations because forsen is a very
strong chess player and
for you fourson i feel like you still
have a lot of good chess
left in store and uh we'll be seeing
more good moves
coming up for sure well
thank you to you both it seems like uh
the producers congratulations
yeah congratulations thank you thank you
guys thank good games folsom
gross man thank you good games guys
so we are about to begin scissors versus
call me carson live that is about to
take place the players
i believe are getting set and
so i mean i'm excited
i'm excited to uh peek into both of
their streams they would both like to
put on a show
yes then with his his music is jamming
scissors whatever
ruckus is going on there sometimes he's
distracted by his dog
sometimes he's jamming sometimes he's
complaining about pain and agony and
chest
so they're entertaining to watch yeah
this is gonna be a very very
you know exciting game too um they've
got a lot of personality going in
yes we'll see that on the board as well
they're two interesting personalities
well we'll be able to see scissors
personality in full display well we take
a quick break
and when we return we will have scissors
call me carson live
in the next match from the chess.com
podcast
all right poppy with a hundred
dollar donation mike's kinda low it was
just a far away from my mouth hundred
dollar dono from roosie poppy can we
please get some love in the chat oh my
gosh thank you so much risky poppy
you did not have to do that
i appreciate that so much
everybody get some of the chat risky
poppy does way way way way too much for
me
like actually way too much for me
so thank you man i hope you're doing
well and i
definitely appreciate all the donors all
the time
thank you
good luck today thank you hopefully and
i mean
hopefully i'm not winning in the second
game and leave a hanging rook
that would not be fun
it still haunts me
and hopefully if it goes to armageddon i
realize that i have five minutes no
increment
hopefully
[Music]
oh my god i'm gonna lose my mind if i
make the same mistakes as last time
yo max zach think of the 800 bits risky
poppy again hundred dollar don't know
pog you dude thank you so much i have
faith in you you got this just
concentrate visualize the wind
got this jack d7 i think in the two
months tsr i think in two months dennis
douglas
three all right e
z collapsed today
again emote only mode once the matches
begin
hydration's half the battle
i'm still okay
is there a live commentary to this yeah
if you go to twitch.tv chess
i don't know who's commentating today
but
twitch.tv chess but also
feel free to keep my stream open too
please love me
too don't don't abandon me like my um
hi hey
simon from staff here hey simon from
staff
here
hello hello hello simon
what do we uh just let you know we'll be
starting about 90 seconds
bring it on get me in there get me in
there and get them out of there get me
in
get them out
perfect
after a fascinating first match we are
back and we are getting ready for
scissors who we were just tuning in for
and call me carson live and well nemo
andrea i'll start with you andrea you
get to go first
tell us about your student playing in
this match
all right scissors so he's a pretty good
soon i have to say i only did one lesson
with him as relatively long he had like
one other coaching session but he was a
pretty strong chess player he's like
1200 1300
i know the last round he choked because
of like
the armageddon time control but i have a
lot of faith in them he
has a good natural instinct in chess he
was naturally
pretty good at it so i think he's ready
for his comeback he's not gonna allow
what happened last round again
okay and nemo on your side of things you
had a lesson with call me carson right
yes yes i did i did have a really short
one actually with collie carson
um i think he's got like a lot of
natural talent for somebody who's done
like chess
twice in his life basically um you know
i i think that he places openings really
well and then
of course when it goes to the middle
game he gets a little bit more confused
but i do think he has a lot of good
chances
um in this match and
well we'll see if carson's been working
on his chess
in the meantime because you know he lost
both games
in his first match and scissors he beat
gripex who was just very impressive
against forsen so that shows that when
ciger is playing his best chess
he's able to take out some of the top
players in pogchamps
well i did peep into carson's just a few
minutes ago he
did say he did not practice for this at
all but
i think he is just saying that just for
show so that scissors will take him
easily while we all know he put in many
many hours over his last match
practicing and grinding for today
uh some players do that other players
really are
people of their word and when they say
they have not been doing any chess
they mean it and at times it shows in
the chess board so
yeah i wanted to give him the benefit of
the doubt but we could also just be
real with it sure i don't want to pick
my two co-commentators against each
other but what are your predictions
for this match not that you have any
bias or anything
yeah well i'm gonna go with scissors how
about you nemo
i feel like i you know i've only played
fall guys with scissors
once and i've actually taught carlson uh
a little bit of chess
i think i do have to go with uh carson
for this one who would have thought
i i thought you just said i've taught
carlson
some chests like their names are very
close wow
sorry sorry it was a fruity and slip
right there
magnus carson yeah magnus carson
well i wonder how he feels about that
because i don't
i would call him magnus carson i don't
know if he'd appreciate it though we
have
e4 by scissors and will
tommy carson play sicilian i like
carson's farm background
yeah that is something i wasn't
expecting that one i have to say for
chad i've never seen chess played in a
farm in the country
oh maybe maybe he's farming scissors
maybe that's picture
metaphor guys baby yeah
well let us find out what he's up to
let's tune his channel and hear
what he is doing let's start off with
this guy yeah
all right i i don't hear any
oh no it is kind of country oh
okay let's think about this it was
country music
the bishop can go this way
[Music]
i don't think that's that bad
that's bad let's do this it's pretty
good actually
oh wow look at this do that chest yes
yes
wait he's got he's playing his game and
managing with like full side production
i don't know
thank you for the 21 months archer
i think he put more effort into his
background than into training
no he put the most effort into his dance
moves true true
it's about the show production that
makes up for the chess playing here
that's true
we should have a new uh we should have a
new tournament called chess and dancing
who can who can dance while playing
yeah yeah you get production around here
i wonder if knights are his fear
i didn't think about it that deeply
there's a lot of things going on here i
think there's a lot of you know takes we
can get from carson's stream but i think
at the end of the day he's just
trying to have a good time and trying to
vibe to music while playing chess i
think i think that's the hot take here
you ever wonder if you're playing well
when you play chess because
i have no idea
i think my opening is kind of hanging on
wait no it's not
no it's not we're good let's return back
to
uh because i have this part here because
already
there is a big tactic available for
carson if he finds d5
because you're attacking this bishop and
you want to play d4 in the next move
working the special e3 the knight of c3
let's see if he's going to find it yeah
what i was going to say about um
carson his openings are very solid as we
saw that in last round so
i was expecting them to be top-notch
again but this is more of a tactical
fight
and i think he needs a little more hips
in his dancing but his chest is
certainly improving mm-hmm i mean
i wish we could say the same for his
dancing
i don't know what's going on here oh his
background makes up for it
yeah his background does make up for him
it's true production value
at all all-time high will he play d5
though he is thinking about it wow
well i hope scissors will be able to
recover from the sport
because if he plays this and let's say
the bishop moves the whole point is the
pawn goes forward
and it hits the bishop on e3 and the
knight in c3 with a fork
winning a minor piece for just one pawn
and he played it he's not expecting that
he played it
i'm so you i'm just sitting here like i
don't know
he's gonna see i don't wanna say
anything but he but he played it i'm so
happy right now
that's a good find it's a very good move
oh my gosh he played it
and there's nothing that siz can do
to avoid losing a piece here if carson
is
intending to push that pawn forward
actually magnus carlsen
magnus carson it's always devastating
like
losing a piece so early in the game
obviously we don't want to experience
the force in again so i really hope
that's
his will keep his head up after this and
yeah
like forsen did but carson probably also
is more likely to blunder
than griffix was i i would imagine that
is true but why don't we listen to
sis and hear what his thoughts are
because he may be going down a piece
soon
yes
what's this artist's name
um personally i prefer edm significantly
over you know over country music but hey
look i still want to go
whatever works for them and
siz as per usual bopping his head in
let's do this wait oh
does he wait wait wait wait wait he
didn't do the four that aggressive
neither player sees the four i don't
think it's the oh my goodness
we're not expecting that one oh
we thought both of them were going to
see it but we were wrong again
maybe maybe um
honestly i just want to sit here and
listen to the music oh my god be honest
i need to push that pawn i feel it the
vibe you know oh that's not good
these are now spots i need to go no it's
just a question of carson
carson i keep saying carlson i swear
oh no oh no oh no oh no he has a fork
ah he sees it though it's a little bit
of realization
you don't see it he's praying don't see
it carson
did you still see it yeah yeah yeah just
you don't just tell carson to not see it
don't do it no no no no no no no come on
come on please
he's just playing i think i want to push
that pawn and now he's making fun of
carson's vision oh god cool the guy
wears glasses i know what it's like
oh he is making my house ah not like
this not like this it's not like blind
like that's
not like downstairs maybe really because
of the glasses
he was just i was joking oh okay i was
like i don't think he thought it out
that much
don't take it too literally there's
nothing to get out of that right you
don't see it
he's telling carson to echo locate and
not
finally threaten if he pushes this
dude why's he taking so long can see the
fork because i remember i taught him
what forks are oh he doesn't see it
never mind i take it back
okay i take it back into carson
he is just jamming i was like no no no
intent to look for tactics yeah he's
just
taken up by the backdrop he's doing
whatever he wants to do
we're bringing carson back on screen
here with both players as we have our
analysis board
queen b6 was the choice of carson which
is generally speaking a pretty good move
it did leave the d5 square lacking one
defender
but scissors so focused on black
pushing d4 he doesn't even think that he
can take this pawn on d5 it's the tunnel
vision
and well andrea you worked with scissors
a bit
did you think that's something that uh
he has been struggling with or just in
this particular moment it was so
threatening that he decided
i need to avoid it and avoid immediately
i think this is a common
issue for all i mean same with hafu who
i was coaching
but not just scissors like most
beginners when they're so scared of a
threat
and they and they realize that their
opponent don't see it like their only
goal for the next move is to prevent it
so not just scissors but i think it
happens a lot in general
for beginners i would definitely say
that's the case and well
now that the center has opened up and
there's a bishop
on e3 staring at the queen on b6 that's
very dangerous for carson because that
night we'll try to jump out of the way
and get a discovered attack but look at
carson go that's not
the center does not care just just
grabbing that pawn you know
carson has like no sense of danger but
it's okay
yeah it's fine honestly yeah like queens
on diagonal whatever oh there's a fork
whatever let's just play with the horses
i'm not sure i i mean he's quite
literally playing with the horsies right
now
with the background that's going on so
you know
there's there's literally like you know
horses running around his back that's
like
he has every right to play with the
horses in this game too oh scissors
that works too actually carson's just on
the old town road you know he's gonna
ride
you can't get no more nice one robert
you know one pop song
because ten points for that reference
what do you mean i know one song
well you think i don't know other
country songs you don't think i know
country i'm talking about pop here that
is not
i would that is i'm not an old town road
counts as country music
i'm not sure oh my god it's okay robert
you're cool don't worry you know
yeah old time road you're one of the
cool kids now you're no longer a boomer
you're you're an honorary zoomer you're
an honorary prove yourself here
yeah honestly getting told that by the
two of you is one of the most meaningful
compliments i've ever received so
thank you so much i i'm gonna stop
talking i'm done
i am retiring from commentary right now
sarcasm but it's okay
you know it's good to take your
co-commentators at their word because
they shouldn't lie to you
on camera in front of you know 32 plus
thousand people so that is a terrible
thing i would never do that
i mean honestly andrea and i would love
to be honorary boomers too but
here we are do zoomers
well let's just listen into carson so i
don't have to be hurt by my coach
[Music]
he just burped thanks for the commentary
robert
oh my god he sure knows how to put on a
show though
wait is he like trying to ride a horse
right now like what's going on
i'm just concerned he hasn't spotted
anything about his queen
he's okay look he reversed pinned white
that's a good move brookie it's a good
move
that's true that's true maybe he doesn't
see it
i can't stand 100 either it wouldn't fit
the vibe
look look at look at this hill behind me
look at me look at this very real hill
right why would i play a hundred gex out
here
what do you want me to disrupt nature do
you want me to make
nature go back to a time that
i don't i don't know what you're asking
of me right now
i'm trying to play chess how much time
does he have this means
how much time he has because i don't
know yeah
that's my thing everyone knows that
where are his clocks
wait did you hear that by the way chess
and country music
and old town road is country so i hope
wait he said that no but i'm saying oh
okay
honestly i think what he's doing is
genius like they call me double pawns
with all the anxiety from the chest so
he's calming himself
did you hear what he just said though
they called me double palms
wait i gotta get that one is that his
new is
you're gonna have to move that ass
you're gonna have to move that ass okay
okay all right this is an important
floor on the board
yeah let's uh come back comment on it
getting tactical
oh that was something wasn't it so this
is getting really sharp
and he saw if we just go back a moment
here when he went e5
he saw that the knight should be pinned
to the queen but i tell this
to everybody just because a piece
shouldn't move doesn't mean that it
cannot move
so knight takes c6 was a very good
response by siz after rook takes d1
knight takes e7 check andrea you've done
a great job
i am proud by his tactics have to say he
was a little bit
worried about them he was telling me oh
too soon i was so too soon
every time i'm never saying anything
especially when it's my student
well let's
it's okay it's still winnable
wait dude wait how long has that been
there
that was the oh my god
he just saw the queen what am i doing
oh my god i'm rushing so much dude
okay good thing he could have taken an
f1 shot
stay calm let's uh go back to the
analysis board to show what you're
saying there
is a very good point that instead of
moving the queen first just like
scissors took a bishop on e7 with check
before because then the king had to move
here after knight takes it rook takes f1
would have been checked so you had to
react to that
and then the queen could have moved from
the b6 square instead
carson uh did not play rook takes rook
and when queen takes b2
and here scissors can steal the rook on
d1
scissors actually has a wonderful tactic
here that would save his knight
and corner the king but i don't know if
you'll see it with bishop c5
king g8 knight check and then taking the
rook on d1
you'd have a lot of counter play i mean
that is obviously a winning position
for for white he's got so much he's
about basically a whole rook here so
um carson carson definitely did not play
the best move with queen takes b2 but
didn't he didn't consider it yeah we got
to work on those puzzles i'm going to
make him
puzzle rush after this it's not a bad
position still
true
please see the checkmate come on
scissors prove yourself to us
you failed us few times but it's not too
late
will he find checkmate in one he will
are you sure
we should uh peek into a stream maybe
i'm very curious
i can't i can everybody stay calm
everything's fine do i move this back i
feel like there's something i can do
here
no no no check not that one
oh you see what he sees he's gonna do it
he's gonna do it
i feel like there's something better i
can do do i go there and protect maybe
oh my god my heart
hey stop oh he doesn't realize that i'm
so mad at myself dude i had his queen
he's still devastated that he can't see
the wind
he also thinks that he's not doing that
exactly he thinks he's still losing
because of that blunder
he really said i really feel like there
was something he's killing me
well he just bounced from his seat and
you two almost bounced out of your
chairs as well because he missed
a checkmate in one move he still has a
rook
and three minor pieces for a queen that
is too much material right three minor
pieces for a queen that's already
quite good compensation but with the
extra rook as well
he still should get this right but we i
think we absolutely we
simply must tune into carson right now
because he's dancing and i have no idea
why
i don't think he even saw himself
getting yeah i don't think he knew he
was doomed
i'm sorry hallie
honestly that's how i want to live
[Music]
he's literally like doing advertisement
for stock footage right now
[Music]
i know he doesn't see anything honestly
look if i could play chess like carson i
would be
ten times happier i'd be a hundred times
happier and he's just not too
emotionally invested big
green tracks yeah you know i would have
freaked out over every single time i got
almost checkmated in one this is yeah
this is uh
what are you thinking about yeah you
know i wish i could play like an easy
man you just take my pawn and then you
basically
am i crazy what is happening with his
various backrests yeah i'm confused
about the trap it looks like my driving
literally and then the fire
yeah this is giving me ptsd andre i
heard you'd like to play bumper cars
it was once okay we all make mistakes
one small crash ultra
yeah no one wants to get in the car with
you it's not fair
i mean if you crashed through three
bucks for cars and one go i feel like
i don't know yeah yeah well they weren't
bumper cars they were real cars but yeah
okay that doesn't make it any better
i mean i don't want to wait how does
that make it better
well let's go back to the analysis board
mainly so everybody can see your face
when we make fun of you for
getting into a car accident although i'm
glad you're okay first of all yeah yeah
we're very glad you're okay
just gave me a little bit of ptsd there
felt like my driving over again
it's okay though i like the horses are
back much much easier on the eyes
well this position is dominant
for scissors but what do you make of the
clock with both players at two minutes
and 30 seconds
carson has a queen and we were listening
into scissors before
he was saying i can't believe i didn't
take that queen he seems frustrated with
himself
will he be able to calm himself and win
this game because he does have
a great position i really hope he can
get out of that mindset because it was
totally like tunnel vision again missing
that win i know time pressure was a main
issue
for him in his armageddon match but it's
good that they're close on time but i
don't know if he can get out of the
pressure
yeah i i think this is like one of those
games where i'm too scared to say
anything at this point after what just
happened the last two moves
both players are you know they they are
vibing you know
like they are having the time of their
life but you know we're here like a
little
yeah he's playing very well though so
maybe i was wrong maybe he's gonna
overcome it
nemo there's no reason to be too scared
you're not in a car with andreas
that's true we can't accidentally have a
three-way car crash
until i visit and i take old two of you
to ice cream and you guys see what a
good driver i am
oh wow thank you very much
no no no no one ever wants to drive with
me it's not fair it's very lonely
it it there may or may not be a reason
there it was good horses andrea how
about this we'll take the horses we can
drive the horses to ice cream places
yeah horses in canada
in the big city sounds like a great
plane yeah let's do it
well speaking of great plans look at
this queen on h4 hitting the knight on
e4
and behind it the bishop on a4 so will
scissors
just react by moving his knight at the
way and in which case he may drop his
bishop
down on a4 or will he protect this
knight with even oh
nice nice look at that move great he's
definitely more focused now
i think he got his head back up after
that mindset turned down
and he just has a little faster that was
a very good move and
he's down to a minute and a half and we
saw him in the armageddon game there was
no
increment in that game but he once he
got himself in the time travel he was
not able to
find these strong moves that we've seen
him play at other moments king the e8
by carson yeah so this is kind of where
you can see
carson's lack of experience in like
middle game positions
um with queens on the board and his rook
has been
has not moved the entire game yet he's
moving the king to the middle
oh and now it's a freak queen
both says [__] and scissors doesn't see
it of course oh he he saw it it's a
bowties gambit declined
oh yeah okay he's going for a checkmate
maybe there's something
yeah there was a check and then hitting
the queen and said he took upon
the more direct win of material but it's
just not as much material king e6
that king is going to get you know it's
going to get checkmated at some point
yeah i think it's coming a good move by
scissors bishop b3 check
so is that king it is going to f5 i
didn't knew i didn't need to ask the
question
yes
he's not going to play g4 check have a
hard time imagining
why why don't you think pushing that
pawn because it makes your king weaker
and
if you don't see an immediate checkmate
that's a very risky move to make
well there is like almost a checkmate in
two right with
with after g4 um i mean it depends on
where black's king goes but but the with
with the way that carson is playing this
i'm not surprised if he wants to put his
king on e4 at this point
i feel like scissors will see g4 because
he's going for all the checks possible
um but i don't know it's also time
fresher he's down a minute
under a minute you probably taught him
don't push pawns in front of your king
to make your king less safe
he went 96 checked i was wrong i was
wrong well
maybe it's a good thing then that either
took my advice i don't know
yeah oh okay look scissors is going for
every single piece he had
another checkmate or no no he didn't
mind
yeah i mean it's close but if he takes
all the pieces then carson at some point
won't have any
and then we can like fully commit to the
checkmate idea right wait nemo is that
is that a good strategy to take all of
your opponent's pieces
well usually usually it's a totally fine
strategy i don't think we'll see a
stalemate from scissors
like you know this is just one of those
positions where where at some point
scissor has to realize that he's
completely winning um
the queen black's queen's not doing
anything he's got the upper hand in this
position actually
but in the meantime if he takes every
single piece then white black will have
no counter plan that would just boost
scissors confidence
well look at the clock by the way 41
seconds for scissors he did just make
another very good move
defending both his bishop and his knight
at the same time putting his bishop on
more advanced square
and carson he's playing chess like he
dances going from side to side
he went from b4 back to h4 so i think
it's a good decision by him oh
okay scissors yeah that one
scissors i think is winning this game
yeah yeah
okay yeah once again i think carson's
strength
but i said at the beginning ended up
showing again he's
very good in the opening well now we see
the bonus
is a gameplay yeah four thirds you're
trying to win on time
i mean yeah it's pretty much the third
at this point it's all right
well let's look at these here we have
them up on screen
everything's fine dude
look at how many pieces okay too many
yeah i believe in scissors but he hasn't
found checkmate
yeah checkmating one there with bishop
to d2 server f2 but it's okay
all right all right all right everybody
calm down i haven't made it to the speed
but let's just let's just oh he knows
just calm down
first i just don't know the quickest way
of
getting mate here carson has two pawns
stay calm yeah
okay okay let's get our rooks in the
same
he's going for the roller checkmate
maybe
oh carson
are they allowed to just panic
honestly i always tell people to never
resign
yeah but except you say you teach people
they never resign but didn't you
teach that one
maybe maybe i didn't teach carson for
long enough maybe i need to teach him a
little more if he's down if he's willing
lesson is a good idea nemo yeah i've
only done it for 30 minutes so you know
sorry guys it's all my fault i i take
the full responsibility as his coach
your lesson plan did not include the
important video
that was xqc foosley from pogchamps
constellation
because if i'm not mistaken there was a
stalemate in that game
and it's always possible yeah dreams do
come true
this was a rough game for carson i
wonder if um
if he'll play you know with a little bit
more determination as white yeah maybe
a little more carefully we'll see i mean
today fair he was vibing he was dancing
this music he was having a good time you
know maybe maybe we need to like
yeah we need to bring maybe a vibe point
to podcast as well true
who's surviving the most that's a very
good idea
i feel like scissors was also vibing
because
he had a variety of songs
going on there he was telling his chat
to calm down non-stop
which is i mean that's what streamers do
right or himself
i think he's talking to himself more
yeah
i i thought it's just a staple of
streaming it's just telling your chat
even when
you're not even having your chat open or
reading anything to tell them to calm
down that
you know what people do no okay
i think
yeah i think even though he lost his
game you know he's uh
i think he won in our hearts he did he
really did
we gotta give him some show points just
a plus one
oh my gosh she was listening to chicken
fried that
would take karu in the background while
he
is producing his own show he's
unbelievable
he's very good at production it's not
we are lucky to have him competing in
pogchamps
yes yes it is an honor to have his extra
production points for our chess show
here
when are they going to get the next game
going it feels like that will happen
in just a few maybe they're having
some production that needs to be done
behind the scenes and
i'll be told the game should start in
less than a minute now i don't know if
they rematched each other yeah i think
scissors hyped over his win
and carson just always is in his own
zone and out in the field
in the country so he won't be hitting
the rematch
you know what i'm going to learn from
carson the next time i play in like an
official online tournament
i'm going to do the same thing you know
i might be playing the online olympiad
or something but i'm going to have
country music blasting in the background
i'm going to have this you know all the
amazing stock footage going on i think
that i think that's what
you know really really interests people
because i am a fan of the stock footage
i am a huge the stock footage was
amazing that was amazing that was that
was content
we got the game going you both are
probably going to call me
a boomer for the reference i'm about to
make because you may not even know what
it is but i really think we should get
some bob o'reilly
from call me carson yeah i don't know
who that is
it's a song i don't know that song
either yeah oh my gosh
it's better no it makes sense high five
andrea
you're on your own you two don't know
good music that's the problem
yeah it's a country song wait but have
you seen
like country is good music have you seen
andrea's like chess.com username
it's literally mo bamba yeah okay i'm
not saying that's a good song
first of all we'll get to that in a
little bit later however
look at carson's setup who taught him
this
uh nemo i won't blame anybody in
particular i teach him any of this i
taught him absolutely
like nothing except one line in the
sicilian whoa whoa
whoa i take no responsibility for his
white openings
okay okay he did play the english last
round so that is his opening
but i don't know about this line
they're not they're not paying me enough
to babysit you two
zoomers
and talk about knight g4 trying to
attack this pawn in f2
what do we think is scissors going to
find that move
um this is like you know that the fried
liver beverages
oh he missed we actually had a game
where we talked about that idea
um but it was not against the english so
i do really like carson's response of
bishop e3 because that
he traded off black's very active bishop
for his bishop that previously been
undeveloped
and this pawn structure to some may look
bad because they're double pawns
but the semi-open f-file in the future
will be good for his rook
that will get there yeah i mean this is
a pretty solid structure for carson i
just wanted to say you know
um to be very very honest i i taught
carson for
30 minutes uh the line i specifically
taught was the sicilian
um with him playing black so you know
we're already seeing him play the
english so
not not nothing to do with me chat
nothing to do with me
just putting that out there nothing to
do with nemo
she says we do not believe until he wins
until he wins and then i'll take
responsibility again
that's how you do it it's like oh i
taught him this exact sequence in the
end game that was
all about that was all me
well i do do think i remember seeing
carson have a lesson with on a rudolph
so he
did work on chess there maybe not as
much as his background
and the horses that are galloping across
his
his screen usually but let me ask you
andrea here
scissors black pieces extremely solid
setup he just made the move
h6 do you think that this is the type of
position that he feels comfortable in or
would he prefer to have this from
carson's perspective
um i'm honestly not too aware about
scissors openings that wasn't something
we focused too much
during our lesson so oh but he at least
he i think he's gonna be aware to not
fall for the same
trick that he noticed a little bit late
last game
they hopefully won't choke here
well here it's coming if says doesn't
move out the way but that's a good move
by carson i really like the way he's
been playing
so why don't we tune in with scissors oh
well he missed it
oh no another fork is he going to see
this one it's the same exact thing
he missed it again i can't handle it
anymore
i can't save fork it's the same fork and
he didn't see it
well honestly i don't think carson never
realized he missed it in the first game
only that's
true but there should have prevented his
second time
i literally think that is
i hope he executes his plan he was
making oh there we go he did
great that's a good move very good move
good
so let's return to the announcements to
show why he's pretty quiet
i thought he would have been more
enthusiastic and lively but we'll
probably see that
when the game is a little bit clearer he
went knight to g4 and his
rook was on d8 or is on d8
pinning his bishop on d3 so he could
have taken advantage of that
by either piling up pressure on the pin
piece with knight to b4 just going after
it
or taking a pawn on c4 because after
bishop takes c4 you can't take back
otherwise you lose your queen on e1 yeah
even the e4 pawn as well right
that's right so knight g4 h well this
worked out even better for him
yeah carson might need a little bit of
tactic training i think tactics would
help him so much because
otherwise is things things at the
beginning so good
yeah uh scissors is playing really
really well
very very well yeah doesn't mean he
won't fall for tactics later though
and still be carson's
game and we saw that happen in grip x
versus forsen
when you have the rooks but may not have
the open files for your rooks
and those you make a pawn move that you
end up regretting here that
it's not quite the same because the rook
on d8 is already very happily placed
here
so i do think that scissors is in a
great
position here and we'll be able to
convert this
i do want to point out that um scissors
is actually double
carson's rating so true it's a it's a
pretty rough match for carson here
there's a hard matchup somehow i think
carson doesn't really take rating into
account when he's playing
maybe i'm wrong but i feel like he
doesn't take a lot of things
into account looked at the ratings he
doesn't even have clothes
on right we gave us these blocks
let's tune in to carson to hear what
he's thinking this song sounds like
marshmallow plenty of facial expressions
no clock
this is the literal reverse of yep clock
there's no clock
to be seen on the screen i know i hope i
love how we went down
viewers when i turned that on
we'll play some t-swifty
he's so focused on the music nemo you
have to give him some tips
you gotta make him focus a little bit on
the chest no you don't
i i think this is um i'm sorry but i'm
gonna focus on
on a few select students no
no you don't oh don't worry i'll take
him under my leg so you're gonna
don't neglect more cars like he has lots
of potential
he does have a lot of potential we just
need to get introduced tactics to him
and i think he's gonna pop off honestly
like
like i feel like he's yeah he's a he has
a lot of natural talent
as soon as andrea heard t swift she's
like i'll teach him
i'm set you're ready oh no
not really the vibe not really the vibe
i don't think oh no
that's not what it was man i just
oh dawg oh no did he just lose oh
stop it oh my god stop yeah you really
need some tactics
yes i think i think i think i'm gonna
i'm gonna message him after
like if he wants to do a tactics
training session just for tactics two
hours
we do we do only tactics [__]
do you video game soundtracks
what he's saying let's go back to the
analysis
makes it sound like he might be upset
but then i look at him and he doesn't
look particularly upset
yeah i don't think he lets it get to him
he's just putting on baseball caps that
say let's collab
yeah you can tell where his priorities
are at which you know
everyone there's nothing wrong with that
but just gotta push him into some tactic
grinding hey look he still wins the
points for vibes
i'm just gonna play that card i'm just
gonna play that card here
his his cap is now on backwards so he is
really feeling it he's getting into the
entertainment
side of things here and ooh rook d1
gives up the rook too oh god i can't
watch it
he's still singing like he doesn't even
affect him when the rook disappears
no it's amazing how scissors has had the
same amount of material advantage in
both games
exactly the same amount of material
advantage wait
that's a good call yes
yeah too much let's put it that way
yeah definitely is there stalemate
possibilities if somehow
you know scissors has taken pink imagine
that king goes to e8
it's literally swapping like that's my
only goal for this game now
you know the position is a little bit
over so i just want that king getting to
e8
that that's my dream for this position
that's uh quite a journey and the
problem
for the stalemate try is that there's a
pawn on on b2
because you can always move that bro
yeah it looks like this king goes to g6
now it's sort of running out of squares
in the near future
like a bishop g4 yeah that would be a
stalemate except for
the fact that there's a pawn on b2 uh
carson's still dancing he's he's vibing
out
i have to say props to him to not
letting him
let losing a game affect his mentality
the good skill to have
although sometimes you probably want a
loss to affect your mentality so that
you
you feel energized to
work on things yeah it's good to have a
sense of danger
um not too extreme that you don't okay
there's so many opportunities now
right so how do you make that happen
though um
you hope your opponent i don't know puts
his queen on g3
okay well that's not going to happen the
queen
queen g2
will see it yeah there's no way white
gets still mated here
okay he's going for the classic roller
mate again queen f3 would be still mate
yeah i mean we just have to get creative
honestly
we'll go here let's listen to scissors
he goes to check me
wait all right am i dumb he's solid and
then here
right okay well that works too oh all
right that was beautiful
ggs don't know what that end game was i
think he just gave up
but i feel like he has decent openings
and starts
and then he just kind of exactly
he does get decent starts at the opening
but
as sister said i think he just gave up
and gave me all his pieces
well yeah andrea your student wins two
nothing over
nemo student here yeah i can't be too
proud of the win because i didn't feel
like it was a
huge fight so i really want carson to
improve a little bit in tactics
but of course i am happy for scissors
yeah it was uh carson tried his best he
didn't have a lot of training so there's
not much i can say about it but
hopefully hopefully he'll get some more
training from either me or anna
yeah no for sure and of course i'm just
messing around nemo
had one quick session with carson he's
extremely busy
i tried to schedule some with him too so
in fact i let him down i'm gonna be
honest
i also let him down so oh no yeah i'm
just letting everybody know
is he preparing his backdrops working on
his production yeah
the production you know if if there was
another
sort of criteria to paw champs um we
would
be we would i would say carson might
have won on the production quality today
i agree and speaking of production we
are going to bring the players
into a call for an interview that means
we will take a short break and when we
return we will have
scissors and call me carson live on
stream
stay tuned everybody
[Music]
and we are back with scissors and call
me carson live we were just talking
about horses
off that's my thing
oh that's a great thing no you don't say
yeah we didn't realize that at all
um did you get upset by my by my horses
or something no we enjoyed them
we improved that was a great touch did
you get upset great
production quality honestly i'm gonna
have to watch this vod back now too
what are you talking about scissors
[Music]
don't throw all the bad things in at
once oh no there's a lot of things you
miss
oh oh that's great carson thank you
thank you
quality content i i put it together this
morning i was like this is gonna be
really cool
and when i win it's gonna be even better
it's really cool it is
it did not end up well yeah okay when
you chose where you want to manage your
time you said okay
practicing for my game or moving horses
in the back of my stream like how did
you make that decision
uh i came to be entertained i didn't
come
i mean like i i came to have a good time
you know
i didn't have a long time i did not
expect coming into this competition to
win
half here for a good time
but carson how did you not play old town
road while you got your horses
that's overdone that's overdone i i
prefer i would prefer like
uh a sexy green tractor or whatever it
was
big
well there was another one oh she thinks
my tractor sexy that's a good one
yeah oh yeah well for for both of you
just one quick thing on the chessboard
in both games and scissors the first
game you actually
saw that it was possible in this one too
pushing this product would have forked
the knight and the bishop so i was not
excited about it i think what i said
when you did that was
was on forked
[Music]
yeah you have forks in both games oh
yeah speaking of scissors the second
time i was expecting you to defend
against it
um as your coach very upset i
don't know what you're talking about it
was all part of the plan
part of the winning plan of course of
course all right i honestly didn't see
the second time
got it third time's a charm yeah
we just have to get that third game in
yeah
oh no armageddon i'm good on all that i
just
as last time i that was that was rough
carson lost every match yeah
well on your end of things right you in
the first time running against uh forsen
that was a really
tough opponent for you and didn't get
any easier with scissors today but
what do you think you've taken away what
have you learned as you've gotten a
little bit more experience under your
belt
wait was he muted or what no he's just
he's just thinking
just thinking oh i
yeah i don't know personally i think you
just gave up too soon
you were so in the game and then you
kind of just threw away your
queen win at the very end of game one
i feel like you i probably got bored
maybe because you kind of just went down
to your king
right away at the end of the first game
i mean he went down his king both
the thing was i was thinking i don't
know how to check mate so he probably
doesn't either
but he did i was i was scared i was
gonna
um stalemate but you know somehow i
figured it out well sis on your end of
things
you had a tough first match where you
almost won but
then it went to armageddon and you
weren't able to take
the three points but now you have taken
three points and moved ahead
into second place in the group how are
you feeling heading into the final match
very confident i will review these games
and i won't blunder the same blunders
against forsen
that's what i like to hear i will take
him
down i've never seen a play but i will
take it i don't know if reviewing the
vods with me is a good idea
because i think a lot of them but it is
but it is a good idea because
you could you were had many positions
where i could have uh
you know been screwed there's a chest
meme right there i just want to say
carson do you do you like
want to practice practice tactics at
some point uh
tactics like like how to play the game
yes yeah yeah how to play chess it might
help you
a little bit in this competition i'm
already i'm already down
four but there's a whole consolation
bracket there yeah you can still win
because i want the constellation
am i in this thing forever he doesn't
know what he signed up for he doesn't
know what he signed up for
yeah no you've signed away your soul
actually to this tournament
oh no
this is a time commitment i hate
commitments well
i mean i tried to schedule a lesson with
you a couple times i feel like we both
were
struggling on the commitments yes yes
would you like to do that sometime
sure i feel i feel asked out publicly
and i have to say yes
but i would absolutely love to hey
sick all right now that all of twitch
knows that you guys are having a lesson
it's going to happen
right yeah now it has to happen it's out
twitch is here
yep do you think i'm cringe no
carson i have to say you have so much
potential as a chess people no one has
the production
value that you have yeah you just couple
it with some tactics
you could kill this thing she's got a
point
i just have horses man hey no no no yeah
what other chest streamer has horses
though
is that a chess joke or is that like a
genuine question
genuine question but i guess you can
throw in the joke there too
all right
oh well that was a very fun match
between you two
i had a good time i we had a good time
tuning into both your streams
yes carson your production value was
awesome enjoy the horses that are still
galloping behind you i'll try and put
something together
yes yes
i'll try and put something together for
next time all right
what can we expect some tactics i'm not
tactics
look everyone's here for carson's
production quality marketing
tactics he wants to help me surprise
call me constellation bracket that i
just found out about
right i'm gonna win the whole
consolation bracket
late tournament run you know i believe
yes
i believe you know my uh i've learned a
thing or two from
from ludwig i'm throwing for content
okay
i get to the lower bracket and then i
have a clean sweep
all the way through once i start
practicing and then
you blow everybody's minds as you make
the run to the face
wait wait but do you remember that love
being lost in
i don't consciously break okay
he may have lost but now who's
commentating on the chess.com stream
it's true that's true i can bring my
horses
on a greater scale
we'll have double the horses we'll have
horses on the board and off the board
buy my merch september 5th no all right
all right okay
and we look forward to seeing your next
matches both of you thank you yep
i look forward to too buy his merch on
september 5th okay
[Laughter]
well we do have another huge match
coming up
we have david pakman taking on xqc
starting in just a few minutes we will
take a quick break and when we return we
will have the final match of the day
in group b of this pog champion david
pac-man
xqc coming up next on the chess.com
pogchamps
[Music]
so
and here we are ready for the final
match of the day at pogchamps
it is david pac-man it is xqc
and andrea nemo
it's david pac-man the kind of humble
soft-spoken uh gentleman at all times it
feels like you know very uh
how do you say you just make sure that
he doesn't offend anybody then you have
xqc
who is the same right what
you're the same right they're very
similar in passali the exact same right
never existed never cuss is very quiet
calm collected
scripts in france they both have the
chill demeanors right
yes yes it'll be a great balance yeah
and well what do we think in this
matchup where i believe xqc has improved
perhaps more than anybody
that we've seen in a short span of time
well it's not that short of spam but
from pogchamps 1
to pogchamps 2 i've been impressed at
least how xqc played
in the opening match against easy with
aces
yeah his game with easy with the ace is
like um
he fought very hard he would go from a
losing position to equal position
also the fact that xqc is not streaming
whereas he was streaming last round
make sure he's taking this more
seriously more focused i make a
difference with his
personality off stream so maybe he will
be a more a little bit more calm today
yeah and also himself very seriously
yeah and i was also
important to note that he last time um
he played against easy with aces i think
he was like
20 hours into stream or something so
today it looks more like he just woke up
oh yeah the exact reversal what happened
last time
we'll see how this goes for him
is it better to be you know just waking
up or have streamed 20 hours which one
is better you know this is this is a
test
well look at david pakman here playing
c3
going for the ponziani who has been
teaching david this because
um this is not a typical move that you
learned
earlier in your chess career i don't
think my sister taught him that either
while she did do some lessons with him
um yeah i have not interacted with
either of these
participants so i don't know but this
opening is really interesting
i believe ludwig actually played this
plays this as white too
yeah it can be very dangerous for black
especially because uh
when you're not so experienced you're
not used to it and the point is that
you're trying to build up
a very strong center and now there's a
stare down the pawns and that's why x2c
played d6
to defend his pawn he reacted but nemo
andrea this pawn e4 could have been
captured at some point but there are
risks to doing that as well as
and so he decides to play calmly yeah i
like this i
it's really really nice to see xqc
taking this game very very seriously
he's calm he's collected he's playing
solid chess this is really good
i like his safe play but it is a little
bit too passive because
now his knight doesn't have good squares
if he goes to e7 he's blocking his dark
squared bishop although he can fion
shadow
so we'll see how he chooses to develop
where do we think he's going to go i
think he's going hopefully not b8
or even a5 would not be good because
b4 traps this knight on the side of the
board i mean
b7 oh sorry nemo you go no i'm just
going to say 97 is not that bad because
you can
write your knight to g6 and you know
yeah the knight can go to f4 later
yeah i like 97 a lot yeah and he's
actually a very solid position
especially without the
pawn tension so because pawns can't
capture each other in some ways there's
less to think about
in the early going and so there's
perhaps less to
uh no less reason to get yourself in
time trouble
if he can find a good plan for
developing his bishop i think he'll be
solid
oh other well he has options right
knight to g6 as you mentioned you can
also
play pawn to g6 and frappuccino the
bishop about the g7
gravity of the bishop and then go for a
knight h5 and f5 those are ideas i see a
lot in
these kind of games um but
you know whatever however xqc oh c6 is a
really good move too
straight away and i'm not surprised he
played that because
the lack of space was undoubtedly
bothering him he plays c6 to chisel at
white center and david pakman
can push his pawn up to c4 to bring in
the reinforcements
and that way once the c pawn takes on d5
he can return the favor with his c
pawn and have a very strong and more
advanced pawn chain on d5 and e4
yeah well this is um i wonder how david
will react here though probably the
worst thing that white could do is take
on c6 and give
xqc oh c4 a great move both players
playing pretty well
yeah solid openings i feel like the more
pog champs that i watch and commenting
on the more likely it is for me to get
in their heads
and consider the moves that they are i
truly i'm not sure that's necessarily
the best for your chess
robert only during the show
so far seven moves in they're playing
great chess that is true that is very
very true
this has been you know grandmaster level
play so far
honestly honestly oh yeah what do you
mean are you saying you don't wish you
played like carson
all day every chess game yeah you're
right you're right andrea
100 greg i i actually really wish you
know
um i could play as well as xcc and david
and david castles and he does so quickly
he has over nine minutes
xrc just dropped below eight and the
position is a bit harder to play
for xqc because he hasn't castled so
he'll need to figure out a way
and he plays bishop g4 do you think he's
going to try to castle
queen side that might be interesting
actually it's
it's not the worst because especially
since it's a little bit difficult for
him to develop on the king side right
now kesley queenside could be okay but i
don't know how aggressive a player david
is because they could
those kind of positions could get like
you know um really tactical really soon
if david decides to open up the position
on the queen side after xqc castle's
there
you have to say xyz is playing some very
original ideas i think his queen side
castle
would be interesting to see as long as
he doesn't neglect his bishop on f8 for
the rest of the game but
b6 is a pretty decent square putting
pressure on b2
yeah and look look at this with bishop
g5 it's what players
in pogchamps love to do themselves and
fear when their opponent does to them
the bishops pinning knights to queens
it's not fun to deal with
because i don't believe they're
typically sure
do i play h3 or do i play h6 when do i
push these pawns to challenge bishop
and when can my opponent just capture my
knight so it's a lot to figure out in
different positions require
different precision and different moves
but what do you think
nemo here how is xuc going to react to
this bishop coming to g5
honestly i feel like one of the most
natural moves people play when the
bishop goes to g5 is to play h6 and you
just give that bishop a kick and most of
the time people tend to take on f6 even
if the bishop goes back to h4
they'll probably play something like g5
um very very common ideas especially i
don't really
i'm not 100 sure where black decides is
going to castle oh knight g6
also a really good move um not even
letting his knight you know not even
letting white play bishop takes f6 and
letting your g-punk get doubled
knight g6 is awesome this is good stuff
yeah excuse he's playing very well now
he can finally develop his dark squid
bishop
and maybe we were wrong about his plans
at queenside castle
we saw him castle queenside against easy
with aces which is probably why i was
thinking he would go that way
and you know he's playing pretty
perfectly in the last couple of months
he's
developed his light square bishop he
made sure to unblock his bishop on f8
which
we were talking about was the
problematic piece and for david pakman
the oh g3 he's one to
stop a knight f4 but that weakens these
light squares
around the uh white king
yeah the one thing i'm afraid about
afraid for david is that he
uh last time i think we saw him crumple
a little bit under the pressure
so i wonder if this time you know he's
he's not streaming he's just really
focusing on his chess game
um yeah he seems pretty determined both
players actually seem really determined
they're they're appearing at their
screen very very intense
intensely and closely and they both did
the same hand thing too
yeah i am glad that they're very focused
because we're seeing
like some great quality play although g3
was not the best move
uh are they the same zoom call with each
other or are they just like
just actually just copying each other's
hand motions perfectly i don't think
they're looking at each other
they're becoming true chess player
because we know very well
when you play in tournaments over the
board people like hmm
[Music]
yeah they don't see the hand the hands
are here always it's just
yeah i think there's also the classic
starfish
look where you're like this yeah there's
many yeah
there's a lot of people just yeah but
but they're both really focused you know
they could literally be mirror images of
each other right now with the way
they're
looking so closely at their screen of
course it's not over the board chest
but um still very very intense gameplay
here from both sides
and a very good move by xuc kicking the
bishop from g5 so
if david were to take on f6 in comes the
queen to f6
piling up pressure on this pin knight on
f3 it's not the end of the world
for david he can drop his bishop back to
block the pin
but xqc is trying to finish his
development castle and
say that his position is perfectly sound
excuse he's been playing like a pro i
have to say
i mean he is a you know a pro gamer
right he is oh and the stretch comes
through and
it's getting serious it's getting
serious you know what that stretch means
all right david makes the best decision
he sees queen of six threats
so he retreats the bishop to d2 and the
benefit of having it here is perhaps
if x2c wants to castle queenside nemo
was saying that you'd open up that side
of the board for white's pieces to
attack
there is a b4 opportunity now with the
visual one d2
yeah i'm a little bit worried about his
time situation though
like he's already down to five minutes
almost it's barely in the game so he
does need to pick up the pace which was
also
a combination of games against vinton
easy with the aces
yeah it's something that's really
difficult i feel like for beginners is
to play
close positions because at some point
you run out of like useful moves to play
right and then you got to start coming
up with a plan how do you open the boy
how where do you put your pieces and
that's the part where people make
mistakes because they get impatient or
you know they just start making random
moves so this is gonna be really
interesting because there's a close
position for both sides it's not like
it's just one side that's
um you know struggling a little bit but
black has a little bit less space here
so i'm just a little bit concerned and
also
running a little lower on time yeah he
plays a6 which is
perhaps aiming for b5 but b5 wouldn't be
a good move anytime soon
with the bishop on d3 and the pawn on c4
teaming up
on this b5 square and i will add that
and i use this
uh term often you know i say the side
with the pawn breaks is off on the side
with the advantage and i think that's
especially true
in new with newer players because they
want to open the position up and
actually bishop e2
allows knight takes e4 that is a pawn
oh and b5 immediately he has tunnel
vision
on that plan i
knew that he was going for b5 as soon as
he played a6 right that sort of
became apparent and two pieces for white
staring right at the b5 square yeah oh
what is queen
e14 the threat or
what he thought was the threat of this
bishop pinning the knight
is probably why he went queen e1 even
though he blocked the pin on the
previous move
with bishop to e2 the queen does help
the bishop potentially get to a5
but i'm worried about bishop h3 trapping
this rook on
f1 i mean that is not to mention that
the pawn on e4 is actually still hanging
and the pawn on c4 is also hanging
um because if you play b take c4 [__]
you take c4 and bishop takes f3
and they're both stuck in their own
plans yeah no no
none of the moves have been played um
both sides have their own plan
going here queen b6 is being played by
excuse me which at least defends the b
pawn so white no longer has that option
and 93 very good move one important
question for
beginners is saying okay why did my
opponent's last move
change and it seems like they're not
they're just so focused on their own
moves they're not noticing what their
opponent's plan is
yeah although i will say that queen v6
was clearly a reaction to
oh yeah solid
he sees the rook is trapped and we'll
see if david pakman
is worried he's losing that rook for the
bishop no matter what there's nothing
that he can do about it so instead of
worrying about that square he can focus
his attention on the queen side
where this pawn on b5 is attacked by too
many of white's pieces
this is some good stuff yeah he has a
pretty winning plan also has future b4
threats winning the pawn on e4
like any good moves for xqc
and for david i think that he needs to
just take this pawn on b5
and try to win that directly because
when the position
opens up it's bad for the side whose
king is
in more danger and the k98 is clearly
less happy
than the king on g1 so nemo what do you
think
will david pakman take this pawn on b5
or will it be focused on the king side
because this bishop sitting here on h3
i think he's going to see oh i said it
i said it i said it like a millisecond
before he played it so he counted it
counted
i made the right one i made the right
you you were
corrected yeah and after the capture in
f1 he can capture with
either well any of his three pieces the
bishop of the queen or the king
all the good but taken with the queen
makes perfect sense lining up
the b5 square
all right andrea what about you so nemo
was right
the pawn was captured on b5 this
position is
not very balanced black has captured a
rook for a bishop in one pawn
but the black king still being in the
center worries me what do you think
yeah if xqc sees the threat of the
bishop b5 he'll play something like
maybe
a5 that would be good blocking that
and not allowing white counter plane i
think he'll be doing just fine then
um i have a feeling he won't take that
pawn
yeah i mean h5 you get knight a4 though
oh true there are still threats yeah
there's a lot of threats and then you
can push b6 and you can't even take the
pawn e4 because well you can't but this
like bishop takes bishop before ideas
and then
everything you know so what do you think
is the worst allowing bishop takes b5 or
allowing
this line that is probably less likely
for david to find but
that's true what i'm thinking is you
know maybe
xqc will do all right
okay that's not what i wanted to say
so i mean he's aware about the king
attack but yeah but castle
into the kingdom yeah other way would
have been much better
i'm into it okay and it's not just
because i told you he was going to
castle queenside
but i saw i think it's so um
really it's rare that people see a
castle queen side
in pogchamps that i think it can really
distract and be
a nuisance for your opponent i don't
think objectively
it's a good move but i do think from a
practical point of view it's hard to
deal with
this kind of maneuver maybe it's the
same positive here
chat yeah i don't think his idea was oh
96 is a very good move from david though
he
i i don't think the long castling's
facing david that much he's just going
for the attack
he's really just putting all of his
pieces towards black's king which
unfortunately just castled right into
you know all the
possibility of mate um
i'm a little bit worried for xqc's
position yeah he
he has to play like queen b eight
otherwise he runs to a7 there's b6 with
tempo bishop takes a six
gas is bottle these tactics with only
three minutes
yeah that's it's going to be painful and
i actually ultimately agree with you
that now that
david found knight a4 it's clear that he
is feeling the position he's
understanding that his pieces
are just quicker to that side of the
board there's a king on seat that is
vulnerable to
attack so i actually completely agree
that david pakman
he has the strong chest foundation to
convert this position the one thing
i will say though the 99a4 no longer
protects the net the pawn e4
so i could see a situation where instead
of going all in for an attack
that may be overwhelming he'll stop for
a second to protect that pawn
and time is important when you're trying
to attack somebody
definitely uh this is just one of those
positions where it's like
black black doesn't have a lot of
counter play here you gotta
okay and we see queen bee queen a7 but
the pawn is going to come down the a6
pawn is going to be lost
um black skin is just on the wrong side
and not a lot of counter play which is
very unfortunate for xqc
so do you think andrea that he'll play
b6 here or take on a6 because i think
b takes a6 is more likely really i i
think tachman will play
b6 that's my left it to me it seems more
natural
like seeing attack attacking the queen
but i also tend to neglect queens a lot
so i don't know
it takes after alex yeah maybe it's just
because it's not my game if i were in
his shoes he's different
oh maybe robert just has a degree in
psych
yeah i did graduate from
pog u okay so that is true okay just so
you all remember that
respected a university there yeah pogue
and now if x there he does it he takes
us pawn e4
this is exactly the type of thing that
can go wrong for a player but i do think
in a sense
that knight 64 can help david play
bishop a5 his bishop is under attack
he wants to figure out where to move
that bishop and now he can bring it over
to the queen side
and put pressure on this rook on d8 and
try to get a piece of the b6 square
yeah bishop a5 will be brutal do you
think he's more likely to defend
i mean robert you were right about your
last prediction with b takes a6 so
do you think he's gonna be aggressive
play bishop a5 i'm gonna throw over to
nemo with that one what do you think
um oh there it is there it is
i i'm not gonna say i've been calling
this game but i feel like
a lot of things that happened have is is
this bad for me
like should i stop commentating on pong
champs because i am predicting spoil it
all
yeah you know exactly what the players
are gonna play at this point you might
as well they're too much in their mind
yeah you're too much of their mind
you're gonna become one of them
and then we can't save you you're gonna
be becoming that's a good thing that's a
good thing
i wanted to make it yeah it was i should
make a joke about robert becoming a
full-time variety streamer
oh that's not a bad thing it's not a bad
thing
i just can't see him doing it wait you
can't see me playing
among us and fall guys
hey wait robert when do you want to play
among us with andrea and i
i've never played among us so fall guys
is first on my list
robert gaming will be entertaining
though yeah it will be all right we can
get a squad going for fall guys animals
robert as a hardcore gamer i have yet to
see it
and maybe with this commentary
continuing he will become a hardcore
multi-variety gamer yep seems unlikely
but perhaps there's a world in which
they have knight b6 check by
david pakman he's going to win this book
on d7
but what's the material count so oh
pretty bad
white has an extra pawn after knight
takes d7 king takes
seven but the king is so out in the open
yeah i mean there's no
chances for xqc it's not like you know
he's down a significant amount of
material actually he's like barely down
material but
yeah it's just the king is so out in the
open and uh david is determined but
however
material does dictate a lot of gameplay
certainly does and well queen h3 check
bringing the queen into the game from
that diagonal will
actually very likely result in
check meaning attack but bishop b5 check
also a good move bishop
five was the more like obvious move i
didn't even spot out queen h3
yeah i mean h3 i was trying to get that
queen all the way into c8 and just yeah
it was a good plan for sure
yeah robert here thinking about how to
get the pawn a8 where i was going to say
this is a good thing for xqc it's harder
for david to find a plan how to push
that pawn and attack the a7 square
yeah i wonder where david's focus is
because so far he's been playing
excellent chess and he's
really been alert on all areas of the
board
but there is that a6 pawn which you're
like i want to get a new queen
oh look at him go nice look at him
mine is exactly there yeah he's bringing
his
all his pieces into attack and uh you
know he only has one more rook to bring
to the attack and at that point
it just feels like black's king is a
little too unsafe oh and he opens up
oh my god and that is all right guys
place your bouts is he gonna see this
yes yeah okay all right he's look at his
face he's looking i mean
he executed that almost perfectly except
yeah
oh he sees that he plays it and he's
like yep the the satisfied
head nod reaction oh
did you see he winced and he's like run
it back let's do run it yeah i'm ready
he's ready to fight he's ready
all right next game he gets white maybe
he can go on the more aggressive
aggressive side
you know get an attack going all those
good things that we want to see from xqc
xbc played overall very well there's
just that b5 plan that doomed him
yeah yeah he went a6 and b5 which was
too
aggressive and then castled in to the
fire over there
and for david pakman he was very
impressive against hafu
in the first match the first game he
played
an opening that was very risky and he
ended up losing that game but in the
second game
he really was out playing her and he had
a winning position and then when he got
to the end game that's where things
started going wrong for him so david has
been playing impressive chess
throughout the entirety of pogba champs
thus far and we'll see if xuc
with the white pieces can sort of change
the nature of this matchup
what do you think are we going to see
david pacman
take his second straight game or is xqc
going to tie this up
i hope xqc ties it up yeah i think for a
rough first round i mean
as long as it's not like a devastating
line coming straight from the middle
game like you said
david messed up in the end game against
hafu so maybe a longer game
gives favors xqc more but i don't know
how strong he is in the end game either
yeah i do also think that'd be really
interesting to see this
match going to armageddon so that's
another reason we will be cheering on um
for xcc to make a comeback
in this next game where he plays white
um honestly he had like a really good
yeah he had some very good ideas but
it's just um
you know running a little alone time
over here played f6
the position was difficult anyway so
it's all about getting that
better position out of the opening maybe
having a little bit more space having a
little bit more attacking chances
and it was impressive how he untangled
his pieces but then he was a bit
too creative for his own good by yeah
pressing forward the way he did so
xqc has shown that he is capable of
coming up with very good ideas and
putting pressure on his opponent
but david pakman also is somebody who
plays very sound
chess like he may make inaccuracies and
some blunders but it doesn't
feel like he's just going to hang his
queen at any point so
um it's a matchup of different styles
and i think the xqc with the white
pieces
the early action will tell how this game
is going to conclude
100 okay we have e4
and c5 by david pakman that means he has
been doing some studying
because oh yeah he's been playing eve
and now we're getting
d6 and night off okay all right this is
gonna be interesting
yeah i think david has been preparing
his openings
from hawfi's games and so
bishop c4 which is what i would say most
players
who are not so experienced to play this
move because they usually play if
black had played let me just change the
position very quickly e5 they often go
knight f3 and have d6
bishop c4 but the difference between
this and
the game is that there's a pawn on c5
and not a pawn on e5 so this pawn can
come to e6 and then to d5 later
as we saw with carson and scissors so
nemo
early on there's a bishop on c4 which
likely makes you happy because
you're the italian player who is
this opening favorite i'm going to say
this open your favors xqc i feel like
xqc does better in open positions
positions where he can push pawns
forward kind of like the last game
um except this in this kind of game he
can actually push the pawns forward on
the king's side because that's the style
of this opening
however um i don't know if he actually
knows how to play this structure it this
is
oh anyways d4 that's pretty good yes it
in andrea like this what so
uh nemo liking it from sqc side of
things it's an open position which he
seems to be
more comfortable with what about you do
you think that david pakman is the one
who chose the opening so
he feels good about it or does this
favor xqc in your
opinion i don't mind david's side
because i play the hype accelerated
dragon which is
almost like you get in this exact
position um you trade the c5 pawn for d4
fianchetto
i think it's comfortable to play for
black
so we don't know what you mean so you
frappuccino right
oh yes yes frappuccino i forgot how to
speak speak the intellectual language
here
you speak the language of pogchamps yes
thank you thank you
university of course
and so both sides of castles we have
some good development for white in the
center of the board but
nemo how should xqc continue here will
he play move like bishop g5 because that
does feel like the move that the
bishop
oh the amount of times that we've seen
this fourth today oh
and and pac david pac-man is like i got
that
look at his little face palm oh
well it's not over
he may be going down a piece but it's
not over especially because his pawn on
d6 will be weak
so let's say white plays bishop g3 the
knight is captured the queen takes
you likely will be able to get a second
pawn on d6 and
the extra material doesn't make its
presence felt just yet
that is also if he makes the correct
decision on which minor piece he should
give
yeah maybe he'll think to give the
bishop instead move his knight here
it's also a critical decision
i mean a move that xqc could potentially
play as knight b5 which
will get you back to d6 bomb but give up
the bishop so
the other option is to save the pair of
bishops and you know attack the d-pawn
leader
it's it's uh there's not some choices
here for xqc
all the pepes in the chat are crying
right now
oh no well choice is
a bad thing at this point because you
know you're losing a piece
so spending time in addition to that
that doesn't seem like it's going to
help your chances so
yeah if he can make the next few moves
quickly i do think that david will slow
down a little
as he's out material and he doesn't want
a repeat of last week
so he will then start using some of his
clock and
trying to make sure that he wins the
game on the board so
xrc needs to just make a move at this
point yeah one thing that players
on this level i think should cry more
often is even when they're losing try to
put their opponents in time pressure and
speed up
um because many of them crumble under
time pressure maybe
losing just stick to stick to speed hey
look i do that in my blitz games too
you know it's a very good strategy you
just press your opponent have that
confidence bluff
you know a lot of a lot of things that
can work
yeah and he's still burning clock now
he's down under
seven minutes in david pakman at 9 49
barely's used any time at this point and
it's unfortunate because as soon as xqc
made the move
he did that face bomb i know he's
defeated inside but maybe not
maybe not yeah and this is another thing
right you have to always remember to
never give up because
not giving up is also a really really
important part about playing
um chess especially in a situation where
anything could literally happen
you just you just just play your
opponent will probably blunder at some
point but you have to have the time you
have to have the right mentality to be
able to catch that blender
at that point which unfortunately won't
happen if you're spending a lot of time
right now
but this is also where not streaming is
hurtful because when you're streaming
and you have a lot of people supporting
you even though you're not reading the
chat
you feel energized knowing that in xqc's
case
35 45 000 people are watching you
you want to do it for them now he's not
streaming and he's trying to do it for
himself and
maybe he doesn't feel as motivated in
that regard right
that's a very interesting point i
definitely
feel energized when i have people in the
chat supporting me so
yeah i think it's definitely when i'm
losing they're like
sad you were losing again loser point of
view only so they're not
always supportive that's true that's
true excuse he has very loyal fans
so like for force and they were still
cheering him on when she wasn't doing
so well yeah and i know of course it's
it's okay to lose too it's okay to lose
that happens it always happens but it's
just like you know
at the end of the day they'll be here
for xqc the fans are here
and they're certainly in the chat right
now i see them
uh showing off their love and support of
xqc and i like what he did
actually putting his knight to b5
because if white were to
receive a free move and that's sometimes
how you should think about the position
and david
back when puts his queen on b6 but let's
say black and minimum h6
random move after the queen trade there
was knight to c7
trapping this rook on a8 so that's why
david pakman said you know i want to
give
knight access to the c7 square so it
puts his queen on b6
and in comes xqc's knight to d6 and i do
think that david pakman will be
somewhat concerned about the attack on
f7
yeah this is a very very good strat from
xcc he's playing aggressive chess which
we like to see
despite being down a piece he's not
giving up i think um
you know just causing problems for your
opponent is always a good idea
yeah i like i like his idea a lot
putting pressure on f7
david is pretty good at spotting the
tactic style as robert said with queen
b6
so he probably won't move his rook
anytime soon
and i think something that might be
tempting to some people is queen takes
b2
but you're taking your queen away from
the defense
he did it wow i was going to say i
didn't think that david was going to do
that
oh this changed the entire game
xqc yeah he can bring this knight into
b5
which threatens c7 threatens to replace
the knight on d6 as you go after f7
and rook b1 we'll trap the queen down
here
he fell for the poison pawn yeah that's
not a pun
that i thought he was going to take so
clearly i can't predict all of their
moves
i was a a one-game commentator
he's shaking his head he knows he messed
up that's what
the thing is yeah i don't know if it's
it's not that bad but um you know
it's it's definitely gonna complicate
things for david it's a lot more
calculation than he probably expected
he's already up a piece he probably is
not thinking about all these kind of
things
um he's just like this game must be
pretty easy for me
so xc definitely has a good chance at
like you know making this game
complicated by playing
knight to b5 not an easy move to play i
must admit he takes an f7 which is
going straight for the king
and so there are some discovered checks
but
you probably just take it if you'd like
on f7
not to mention that this knight on c3
can be captured because once you take on
c3
the queen hits the bishop on c4 yeah
that's i think that's the winning move
for black here because the eval bar
dropped
that's a hard move to play though right
because you're walking in to a
discovered check
yeah if he continues with rook takes f7
and the same plan we were speaking about
with knife e5
might still be possible but maybe david
will
find the harder option well rook f7
actually may be
bad but it's hard to see because queen
dhl forces bishop back and i could take
your knight on f6
because everything is pinned yeah
there's a lot of tactics here i mean
it's just that
i don't will david see that he might he
might um
but you know it's it's it comes down to
almost a 50 50 percent chance between
you take you know say three versus
you taking off seven and it's so
difficult
for to walk into a check right by taking
on c3 you're allowing a discovered check
but if david has been doing his tactics
if he feels like let me just take a
breath
it's just a check it's not checkmate
then he'll be able to take this knight
on c3 but i feel like it's a really hard
thing to do
in a game like this uh and he took on f7
oh
oh i think he sees it i think he sees it
he's like
look at him he's like look at him yeah
he's got this i wish we could hear him
right now
yeah oh no it's the
ice skater right it's it's just going
right across the board it's not a
background checkmate
goodness because the bishop can block
but he wants to look at him he's getting
ready
yeah he just shook his head he's like
shaking off his sleeve you know he's
waking up
yeah he's finally waking up he thought
head shake that was it
yeah it's no longer ah and david pakman
also sees it
the reactions are absolutely hilarious
he's like boss champ exactly
you see the evaluation bar say checkmate
in five moves
it's not so straightforward because it's
not check yeah check check check
mate but he found queen d8 so step one
complete after bishop f8 though will he
see that the rook is pinned and then he
can win this
knight and then the rook next or will he
say i'm gonna take your bishop because
that's hanging which is
still not a bad decision for white right
you're taking a piece there
and the rook is still pinned but i
wonder if he is going to see
queen takes f6 next as the rook is
pinned to the king
these are some very this is a very good
position very promising position for xqc
no matter what happens and
only one move available for david pakman
yeah in positions like this david should
not be wasting any time
because clearly can't move his rook and
knight is a free piece he should spend a
second
good he brings it back and will
xqc find the dagger queen
takes f6 the dagger the bing the bang
and the boom all at once with the queen
taking enough
bang oh this is uh this is the moment
you guys leave
chapel oh i'm nervous honestly
my heart is racing i have to admit i
hope he finds it
because then we'll get an armageddon
maybe yeah oregon is always fun to watch
too
yeah i think he's very focused
he is david pakman was baited into this
you know he won a piece which is great
but then his king started feeling a
little iffy
and that's what happens when you leave
the queens on the board he could have
traded queens
but then he was worried earlier i'll
just show that position really quickly
and he was worried about this knight
coming into c7 so he decided to
keep the queens on the board and maybe
andre you said this earlier because he
lost in an end game when he was actually
winning
maybe he just doesn't want to get to an
end game yeah maybe he's a little bit
scared
and so here we sit
i is he going to take on f6 i feel like
the more he thinks
the more he's going to doubt himself a
little right it's like and he's got oh
he takes the rook
okay it's so good yeah so good but
he's still winning he's going to take
this bishop next
that bishop is under attack do you think
he'll see it or
will try to save his knight instead well
thankfully for him
taking the bishop also defends the
knight but
and he but xcc doesn't seem that
thrilled you see him shaking his head
yeah maybe he saw he could play queen
takes f6
right after he played it but i mean
there's no going back now
i think it's just a thinking face
honestly okay
well he hasn't played queen takes c8 and
that's a worrying sign
as he did just decide to take that look
there
that's what i'm saying i don't think oh
okay oh
the check wait it's one side
away so close yeah knight d7 is actually
knight b d7 is actually going to be and
block the check
right blocks the check the rook protects
the bishop the bishop can also block on
e7 and the reason why i will say this
game is so far from over
is there's a king on f7 so even if you
block the first
check i don't think that david is happy
about his king
being out here and david is a good
player we saw it in
the matchup against hafu we're seeing it
again today
like he's capable even having his king
on the open he's capable of
stifling and styming his opponent's
threats and then playing for a win
himself but
what do you two think do you think that
the weak king is going to
pose him some serious problems i feel
like it is
it is going to pose a little bit of
problem but i'm a little bit worried
about xqc's time as well
and he plays 97 just defending the
bishop and also developing the knight
black is pretty well defended here i
don't know
how much xbc can come after the black
king here yeah even with quincy for a
check there's always king g7 or
something
right we just don't have enough pieces
because black has
three minor pieces for the rook that was
lost that's a ton of material
yep so
how to press forward here maybe f4 at
some point but f4 will allow
queen to b6 check getting those queens
off the board and that should make
black's king feel a lot better yeah
syria should be going for comfortable
moves especially with his time situation
like
rook d1 hopefully he
do one you know simple plan so that the
bishop has to stay on
c8 and develop the knights um
i'm more worried about his time though
yeah
the the time is yep clock this is a yep
clock moment guys
um clock's sticking down xqc needs to
play some active chess but it's a little
bit hard finding a clear plan in a
position where you're down material and
you can't really attack his king anymore
he's he's not down that much but okay he
goes for the one check but kim ji
king g7 will secure the king well indeed
and then what will his follow-up be will
he try to
bring his knight to b5 he's shown that
he likes knight getting that square will
play rook to b1
to attack the queen it's
not super easy for black to continue
either but with the three minor pieces
uh of course david pakman's position is
excellent
yeah rook b1 would be like the fastest
thing for time saving because he could
get another tempo after rook b3
um but now there's also a huge weakness
on e6 so his knight is
pretty useful he could night maneuver
like knight b5 knight c7
there's lots of ideas for him even
though he's down yeah
getting the knight to e6 would be
fantastic and
nemo what do you think is he going to go
for knight b5 or
maybe move the rook or play f4 too many
options with a lot of options
yeah oh it plays 95. i like the
prediction
okay andrea seems like you're turning
into the
uh the pog whisperer here i think i'm
just the pega whisperer we get each
other you know
oh my brain i always i always get jokes
how
well doing many similar mega moments
the move is great it also threatens rook
to be one trapping the queen on b2 so
that
queen needs to move its way back with
the move like queen to b4
and that way your king starts feeling a
little bit safer as your queen is
trying to maybe even get back to e7 but
the queen is in danger being trapped
which is not
actually easy to see for either player
yeah i i do think that david pakman even
going by the basic principles of
positions in which he's up material he
should play queen before it's almost his
only move as well so
let's see if he plays it i think
considering earlier he didn't realize
the danger of queen b2
i have a feeling you might not see rook
b1
that is true too that is very very true
i honestly it's
it's like yeah if he sees queen before
this game is gonna be very difficult for
xqc to play but
if he if you know if he if he doesn't
see it then
xqc has every single chance to win this
position well let's go back
to that thought about match one where we
got to an end game
and that's when david didn't feel
comfortable so perhaps because that he
will not
want to trade queens like we can ask him
in the interview i have no degree of
certainty yeah
with respect to that notion but it
doesn't seem like he wants to trade
queens
yeah that would definitely be his best
bet he might just be reluctant
for any queen trade which is holding him
back a lot
and andre your idea with knight coming
to c7 and that you
you looked at e6 square you said that's
one
where my pieces belong whether it's my
queen or my knight and that knight
would head right to e6 and cause black
some serious problems
with that check and hitting the bishop
as well so the knight is trying to make
a long journey from c3 into e6 and
the first step was definitely a good one
yeah that's the main thing i try to
teach
like any of my pogchamp students as well
like pointing out weak squares
immediately after move because then it's
very easy for them to formulate a plan
yeah that is a very very smart idea
and you know even despite being down
material there's always things to play
for right and that's a big
part about not giving up so david's time
is running down low as well
uh we might see a time scramble yeah
between
these two players say what i saw between
ha fu oh
oh the queen is oh wait that's actually
a really good move because
oh he played quick wait no you know that
was quick that was good
he invited the plan this is getting
dangerous for the king
even though it saved the queen right
it was a trade-off now the queen has the
a3 square to jump to eventually
but you first have to move the rook away
and then andrea's plan
is going to show up on the board yeah
this is a very very good plan and you
bring your
more material into the attack more
chances you'll have for
you know just causing mayhem in general
and david has to move his work
wait he that's that's a really really
interesting move he's like i absolutely
refuse to let knight e6 happen
attacking the queen um wow yeah that was
a pretty brilliant move
but i think i don't even know honestly
the best response for white
yet i have to calculate i think he needs
to play quickly and play queen to d3 and
if this rook moves from a8 you play rook
to b1
and try to get this knight on b6 so the
good news is the
e6 square is covered the bad news is the
knight goes in the same line as a queen
so
and also xqc's time is oh and he plays
96 anyways well he won't be losing the
queen but bishop takes e6
and uh white will have no more minor
pieces which also means his attack
is going to be a lot more difficult
where you don't have pieces
yeah with the queen d3 move it's
honestly a pretty good move like what
the plan robert pointed out but i don't
think
xqc wants to give up on his plan that he
was so emotionally invested in
which is common mistake that i also do a
lot
yeah and here david can take this knight
directly on e6 but he can actually move
his king
and that's a very hard thing to do is
when you're in check and it looks like
pieces are coming after you to leave it
on that square especially
considering the bishop seat hasn't moved
yet but he can he does take it he could
have moved his king first
and that way the knight would have been
on a vulnerable square so we have a
trade
and rookie one next is a very big threat
but look at david pakman go he attacks
the queen on
uh e6 first david backmans are playing
very solidly
very very solidly like it's it's
something else to see you know because
most people
in this um in this podcamp so far i've
been mostly involved with pushing pieces
forward
not caring so much about what their
opponent does but david pakman has this
prophylactic kind of thinking going on
and it's really impressive because he's
like yeah my opponent wants to play
96 i'm gonna stop that um on all of
these kind of ideas that
you have we don't see that often because
everyone tends to get a little bit more
tunnel vision
that's a really good observation time is
sticking
yeah the time oh yep clock guys yeah
oh god no no okay so rook be one i
understand the point but
will david pakman see that he can
actually finally trade queens
will he take on b1 though because that's
what you can do as if queen takes b1
you take the queen the black rook takes
the white queen and if you take here
then the white the black queen continues
to be crazy and take rooks before
finally taking the queen so let's go
back to the live board because in fact
rookie 6 rook b2
so we are trading in b7 though
all right no hesitation there i actually
think the rooks are better than the
minor pieces
in this game i do think so too um just
because
i feel like xqc can utilize them a lot
better than david pac-man will know how
to use that bishop at night
realistically speaking it's just not
something you get very often i feel like
in when you're newer to chess so you're
like trying to coordinate these
two knights in a bishop but the rooks
you know they just want to line up
yeah rip froze brook bros exactly
so wait rook d8
and that hits like the knights it hits
the bishop here things are getting
awkward
yeah oh he plays it so fast wow look at
that tactical genius
good xqc right here
and now it is looking the game is
turning in xqc's favor not that he's
better just yet
but we've seen that david pakman you
know he's been so solid throughout right
now it's getting uncomfortable with all
of his minor pieces under threat by
these rooks
wow look at that very impressive tackle
gameplay from xqc
um his time is running low but you know
the the instincts are there
from a pro gamer and look at this david
pakman about to even up the clock
situation as he is
going into 22 21 and up 26 main weakness
oh that's a knight that you can just
take oh
so if xg does it look at that
oh my gosh so david can take on e4 the
free pawn
he does
[Music]
the reason i don't love it is because
bishop c5 check but i think that david
without time is just going to retreat
his knight as he
did and good move
hitting the pawn putting some pressure
on the knight that the knight is
protected you just
can't forget that certain pieces are
defended
now what you guys were saying earlier
about the rooks being easier like
personally i prefer the minor pieces but
at this level just like these natural
rook moves are so much easier to find
yeah you just have to put your uh rooks
together and they'll be safe but with
minor pieces you can lose them at any
time
right and the knight on b7 in particular
is an awkward piece bring this rook to
d5
and you just can coordinate them so well
rookie iii is also plenty good just do
not
fall victim to the ice skater right you
need to you need to make space for your
king at some point
so xcc first needs to save his rook he
just did that
and eventually he needs to push some of
his pawns from his king preferably
his g-pawn yeah and
aslan's excuse he doesn't lose his rook
accidentally he he's defending his work
really well
um david is going to struggle a little
bit with finding moves he's finally up
yeah about time too up on time this is a
big
big you know switch from from the most
of the game
and look at him go with g4 maybe he'll
try to h4 and create a checkmating net
oh that'd be beautiful but i think david
trying to defend with the rook h8 maybe
oh that's just so passive there must be
a checkmate playing rook to d5 as well
yeah would be beautiful oh
okay he keeps hitting himself in the
head yeah i don't know what he's seeing
but
uh he's definitely better oh g5 bishop
g5
okay so so now you don't no longer have
h4 but
i don't know about losing the f pawn
though yeah he doubled up his rooks
which is stacking the rooks generally
a good strategy but not when it caused
jobs but look david pakman in only 8.7
seconds when he made that move
and h3 excuse me okay now
whoa hitting the rock right but rick d1
is going to come back
okay we're defending that's good too
and now he could go f4 g5 yeah
f4 would be a really good move here
black has to play g5
yeah yes
knight d5 would be there it is but david
pakman going right after the pawn and
looking out okay he's going for the past
pawn instead
i like this this is this is really good
stuff from both sides
very impressive how they're performing
on a time
so david wants to bring his knight to f4
it looks like that's kind of the idea
but look at xqc
bring his rook in the a6 pawn can be
captured if he wants it
or rook to d1 bring his next rook in f6
wait that's a freak there's the guy that
the head smack came in
it's okay but he's okay if he just takes
an a6
okay rookie seven checks also fine he
lost a very valuable pawn
but there's so many chances he has
another pass pawn maybe
maybe the pin is actually going to work
in xqc's favor too just because your
pieces are going to tie down if rookie
six happens then you'll probably lose
the eight pawn
a lot of good chances here for white
wasn't a rook
there we go good move for k7 the knight
can't move and the
oh the rook's hanging there
oh my god he took it xqc
sees it and wins the rook david all
right this is looking like pressure
again
this is looking like xqc's game now
we're gonna see armageddon
sqc look at that
xqc did not crumble under time pressure
and so he needs to make sure he keeps
his rooks defending king g7
bring your rook to f5 or to f3 just make
sure you do not
drop that rook and bring oh he's going
for the checkmate yeah but bishop g3
oh no
oh god he's so mad okay
oh but it's okay but it's okay white's
those really good practical winning
chances in this position with the two
passports oh no
it's not over guys it's not over push
the eight
over yeah king up is okay too but push
that a pawn
i really wish we could have heard his
raging moments but yes
gosh and king king d3 he needs to make
sure not to go king d5 because if he
goes king d5 there'll be knight v6
do not go king d5 because 96 forks
oh there's still very good chance i mean
x2cc technically is still winning in
this condition just because for another
rook no
yeah oh he pushed this ball beautiful
okay good move by xqc and david knight
b6
good move by him so you need to keep the
rook on the a file to so you don't drop
your passport
oh god there goes the other rook oh no
oh no
oh man oh okay that that's not so bad
this was such a great game
that was an amazing game that was
painful but it's not over yet
it's not over yet he does have a past
pawn and even king d5
if he can bring that king in but does
knight c7 check
if dave pacquiao finds an ic7 if he
doesn't die
[Music]
and xqc
unfortunately for him he had two rooks
against two minor pieces but both of his
rooks have now been captured
and he's just going to try and push his
past pawn hoping that he can get to the
other side
it just seems like david pakman has it
under control now
it was a very good game by excuse just
the time at the end
if he goes king he ate or c7 oh he's he
needs to make sure he does not bring his
king
and he brings his bishop back to stop
there guys
bishop a5 keep that bishop on the
diagonal
yeah once was he get that c pawn oh
david looks like he
he he's just um he just smacked his head
a little bit over there i'm not sure if
he sees bishop i'm sure he's going to
find a way to
um play bishop a5 but he says
oh my goodness i'm going to track the
knight for
the pawn on c7 but how he needs to
you know the thing is if king of six
then okay he brought the knight up king
to d6 now
oh and if he goes 94 he might be 94 to
keep checking he might think that no
looking no not a6 okay
wow that's that's a really good move
okay but there's there's good chance is
to hear still it's not over it's not
over
it's definitely not over very good
chances for xqc to hold this position
and now knight b8 could have been played
to take a closer look
oh we're just gonna create the pass pawn
and then the king black's king is really
close
to the to white's pass pawn so the
promotion is going to happen from
from david so david breaks free that
pawn king c8
to b7 would be like the only chance that
you have to try to chase that knight
away but it seems like
david pac-man he stood
some serious pressure on this one oh my
gosh
it feels like david is during time
pressure like we saw earlier
and uh the other day he's he he doesn't
do too well under time pressure so
he's only oh no oh he gave up the night
and he just lost the night there
okay but he promotes but does he know
how to use a queen yeah
i don't know if he knows how to win the
senate he's a draw is still winning for
him
unfortunately for xqc that's right a
draw still winning
but i'm not sure if he knows how to use
a queen to
queen and king combo for this the idea
is that you have to check the king so
that the king goes in front of your the
past pawn on cn and you bring your king
over slowly to capture the pawn
but um that's a very advanced endgame
idea
right especially in a position like this
because you're forcing the opponent's
king up the board like queen f6
that's not the right start but he can
just give checks forever
and as you said make the draw and that
way when the match
and he knows this too yeah he definitely
he can just stack his queen for c7 then
take the h
pawn he can force the draw in many ways
i mean force winning this match
right queen e4 check this is something
that
um i oh he allowed the queen
that's all right it's uh yeah i i think
he didn't see that but the king is close
enough to the pawn where
you're gonna be able to capture it and
that's will be a fourth straw
and everything is yelling it's like you
didn't expect it
to be a draw i really wish the xcc were
streaming so we could
have heard his thoughts that was
one of if not the best games of both the
first
and this pog champs i mean that wasn't
really something it was very impressive
xpc played very well sir david yeah huge
respect to both players xcc played
amazingly and so did david of course but
xqc had a very good winning chances here
you know
might see a even better gameplay from
his next game
well we'll hear from the players in just
a few moments we're going to take our
final break and when we return we will
have xqc and david pakman
and hear how they feel after what was an
epic battle we'll be right back
[Music]
moreches.com
so
[Music]
and we return with both david pakman and
xqc and david we'll start with you
congratulations and i have to ask
how nervous were you down the stretch of
that second game when you both were in
immense time trouble
i was getting pretty nervous yeah and
what i tried to remember was with
increment
last time in game two i just played the
entire rest of the game
as if i had 25 seconds left even though
i had built it back up to like two
minutes so i tried to remember that that
was not
the case this time but this it was a
major major collapse and i'm lucky to
have
i mean listen after last match
i'll take any win that i can get
but um there was a bit of a collapse
there we're gonna have to be analyzing
that one for a while
and xuc you played a really great second
game
with some aggressive play there after
you had blundered a piece
did you feel like your gameplay was
better today because we were all quite
impressed
uh nah i blundered so hard i was kind of
defeated there dude
but my my boy a white shirt walter
had to push a draw on a 600 elo
player come on man
i dropped it come on
i was going for the home stretcher dude
yes well listen i'm lucky to have gotten
the draw i almost lost so
yeah you both played really really well
today
it was an amazing amazing game
yeah and well let's look at the second
game because the first game
uh was pretty wild as was the second one
and
we'll go back to that critical moment
where david you did not trade queens
uh when you could have when you were up
a piece was that because you were having
some ptsd from last week against hafu in
the end game
wait so this is game two witch move um
you went
your queen out to b6 on move ten when
you could have traded queens off for
instance and you were up a piece for a
pawn at this point
uh yeah yeah i mean i guess
i just didn't see any particularly good
reason to trade the queens
and then it would have brought i i just
you know obviously i'm terrible at this
so who knows
why i would do anything but don't be so
hard on yourself
you're doing great you're doing great
you need to be so hard for yourself
i couldn't justify trading the queens so
i figured
that there was maybe some opportunity
with the two knights and the bishops
stacked up on the bnc files to maybe
later
get the queen there and in fact had i
not collapsed later
i was looking at taking either the c
pawn or the knight on c3 but i never got
got the time really because things fell
apart
in xuc you went for a vicious attack
with
knight takes f7 and after rook takes f7
it was actually you who had a chance to
end the game pretty quickly because you
brought the queen down
i was like that's a good start and after
bishop f8 did you consider the move
queen takes knight on f6 listen
i it's one of those things where like
good chess players see like all
scenarios and they see them through
like if i think of a scenario and i see
it through and
there's another one that appears it's
like i forget what the other one was
like
and i can't like like do a fusion and i
i didn't remember that
um with that new line of thought that
rook was pinned
right and i was like okay well a rook
will they queen
i've forgotten uh that i already thought
that that plan outs
so i i didn't know like i just forgot
that it was pending it's just bad
that was a very complex way of saying he
just missed the pin but i see
yeah we we get it and we understand
well you're juggling variations right
and david i'm sure you can attest to
this as well
that when you're dealing with so many
different ideas that
in one line you may remember a certain
tactic but in another
you forget right uh yes
forgetting is um i mean i've forgotten
way more than i've remembered in this
game already that's the crazy thing
and did with that queen trade middle i
was like dude
take my queen dude take it man if you
want to win did
did i want to see blood man if you're
going to get the w out of this
i want you to fight for it dude come get
my pieces bro
queen sis oh that's interesting i like
that yeah
and i guess you you guys did get into
this queenless position
and it started to turn in xqc's favor
where
david you were in time trouble and you
were fending it off for
a while but then you got into this
position where your
knight was pinned i'm gonna go to that
moment right now and unfortunately
you didn't either recall that your rook
was hanging or you just didn't see
that the rook on f1 was staring down
through your night the rook and f8
no it was a fiasco and i mean i got
lucky on a couple of uh
forks at the end where i was able to
pick up some ponds and sort of like
salvage it but it was uh
it was by sheer instinct alone and my
instinct is usually not super good so
that was
it was lucky for everybody also he no
scope mike uh
my rook and i didn't even see it he said
all across the board
yep no scope yep that was a nice find
that was a clutch saved by you david i
think up in the up
until that point i was like we're good
we're going to armageddon
yeah yeah we thought so too yeah because
you see you were just trying to give
that quick checkmate right you were
trying to the ladder with the rooks and
yeah i wish i did the scissor lift or
whatever you call that or you like uh
like like chick chick chick chick chick
chick yeah yeah yeah yeah the ladder yep
yeah i was certainly aware that that
could be coming so i was trying to think
of
you know making sure i had a spot to
kind of hide the king if it came to that
and unfortunately like with f5 and h5
covered by the pawn uh i was
i knew i needed i knew i needed forks i
was looking for utensils
i would have taken anything but i was
looking for forks well
you got one of them and then xqc still
had a good position and unfortunately
for him he dropped the rook here on a8
when the knight came to b6 so
uh what's interesting is i'm looking at
the evaluation bar
when i got this fork it went more in his
favor
well i wouldn't necessarily agree with
that it's
it's kind of complicated the position is
still winning for
white because of the past pawn and xqc
started on the right foot
and he tried to push that opponent all
the way through but unfortunately for
him
you were being all tricky with your
night and night yeah do you think that
night is the trickiest piece for
you guys because i feel like that's been
the theme in pogchamps
you know what you know what i i feel
like lately after doing a bunch of
puzzles i think night is the only
piece that actually put thought in like
uh
yeah i i agree and i agree in that
because i know that it's trickier i feel
like i also am thinking way more about
like
in two or three moves where could the
night be
yeah and after this i mean once you lost
the rook xtc there went your winning
chances
uh it felt and that dave was able to
secure the half point he needed so
what a crazy match it was andrea what
thoughts do you have of
that match up any questions for either
player um i had a question for xqc
like i thought this was one of his best
games out of all pog champs
i know he took a day off or i don't know
how much of the day which is very rare
for him
were you preparing a little bit before
this like doing any puzzles today or
did you go into it like last time guys
before
i had this little uh rare tummy ache
because i was just chilling
i was just sleeping and napping well you
played very well but
okay so you didn't prepare yourself for
it but it's okay because he still did
great
that's right um yeah am i am i out
completely or do i have a chance to
redeem it
um well we don't know because these uh
other two players in your group will be
playing not tomorrow which is the rest
day of the day after so
we'll see how that shakes out but i
think that
you still have a chance and if not
you'll be in the constellation bracket
and we know that you can be a force in
that
okay sure make sense yeah and david i
have a question for you because
you know throughout you've been very
solid and maybe in the first match your
first game the opening was a little bit
uh risky
it feels like you have a good foundation
so what is your chest
background like and what have you been
doing lately to work on your game
uh my background is really about 18
months ago i just started playing online
um up until that point i did i was
extremely solid on how the pieces move
so like i would never
think you know a rook moves diagonally
like i was super solid on that type of
thing
but um no i mean i've just been playing
online for 18 months
and then just you know training training
for this quite frankly
oh well you've been training well it
seems and uh
you have a very impressive foundation as
i've said and
it seems like you you know you're a very
solid player like you
know how to minimize the risk for
yourself most often and then that causes
problems for your opponent so i've been
impressed by that
now what was the riskiness of the in the
opening with just
the opening in general is a risky one so
i meant the first game against
hafu yeah oh oh and against hobby oh my
god that's what you call
a gambit gone bad i mean it's called a
gambit for a reason right and
uh i was on the the wrong end of that
one yeah no today was a different story
the game was hoffu was the one i was
referring to but it seems like you've
shored that up
and nemo any final questions before we
let these two players go
no i just have to say both players
played absolutely amazing today and it's
great to see xqc you know play really
really well
and there's always a chance to you know
win the last game
um whether it's win the entire
constellation bracket or just win the
last match there's a lot of good great
chances here for both of you
thank you well thank you both it was
awesome
all right thanks guys really appreciate
it all right guys have a good reason
thank you bye and that was david pakman
next qc joining us after what
seriously was one of the best games in
pogchamps history
we note that tomorrow the 25th you'll
see there are no matches it is a day off
from pogchamps there will be speed chest
champion grand prix action but no pog
chance we will return on the 26th
with some fun matches between hafu and
easy with aces and wagon mama tv against
connor eats pants doesn't sound tasty
but it does
my my 30-minute prodigy students
well are you going to work with any of
these players tomorrow neymar i might
have another lesson with
connor um it is his birthday so he was
trying to get his round moved i don't
know if it did
i know he's turning like 21 i think on
wednesday
so it depends when we're gonna fit in a
lesson for his birthday celebration
yeah well i mean happy early birthday to
your student from us
yeah happy birthday happy birthday yeah
i'll be working with blade um probably
on the 26th just hopefully a day before
his next game there's a lot of things
that he can still work on but he's doing
amazing he's leading group c currently
and as we see in front of us we now have
the clear leader
in group a that is gripex he beat
forsen and that means the matchup
between forsen and scissors will be for
the second qualifier
to the championship bracket in group b
we saw david pakman win his match he is
now tied
with easy with aces and it's hafu who
will play on wednesday
and xuc will have a chance against izafu
in the final matchup in group b and as
you see in group c in group d
early stages with only one match down
nemo
i also wanted to congratulate you
because you've had a
recent important announcement have you
not you've uh
signed a little deal haven't you yes yes
um
well here we are clg nemo which is i
guess the first
chess slash variety streamer with an orc
so this is very exciting for me
congratulations and we're very proud
thank you
thank you huge congrats to you and
andrea well this was your first foray
into commentating such a big event how
are you feeling after your first go
i have to say i wouldn't have wanted to
done it with anyone else so thank you so
much robert nemo for making it like a
great experience very comfortable for me
i'm definitely now going into commentary
in the future
feel more prepared and i know it's
something that i want to do more often
so i really appreciate that
a lot of fun
yeah it certainly was and i look forward
to commenting more with both of you i
want to thank all of our fans and
supporters
the staff behind the scenes doing such
hard work
all of the players who were not just
showing off some good chess but also
great interviews those were a lot of fun
and well with that
we will bid you all to do until
wednesday for more pog champs and
tomorrow there will be speeches
championship grand prix
on twitch.tv slash chess see you next
time
are you playing that to be seen
i i'll leave it a secret okay exciting
all right thank you everybody thank you
guys right after the stream actually
yep catch you later all right
[Music]
so
you